heute und morgen da muss man abwarten ob
hinterher wirklich ziel war es dabei
rauskommt jedenfalls wird der
Bundeskanzler hier gleich seine
Regierungserklärung abhalten und er wird
sicherlich viel zu erklären haben dass
eben die deutsch-französische
Ministerrunde kommenden Mittwoch
abgesagt wurde gestern das ist schon
überraschend und das ist auch nicht gut
in Zeiten wo Europa eigentlich
zusammenhalten müsste wenn diese Achse
schwächelt und damit gebe ich rein in
den Plenarsaal
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung
gratuliere ich
nachträglich dem Kollegen Dr Helge braun
zu seinem 50 Geburtstag
alles Gute im Namen des ganzen Hauses
ich komme nun zur Tagesordnung
interfraktionell wurde vereinbart dass
den Tagesordnungspunkt 8 Buchstabe a
abzusetzen und Buchstabe b mit denen
ohne debattenpunkten aufzurufen im
Anschluss an Tagesordnungspunkt 7 sollen
nun Tagesordnungspunkt 14 mit einer
debattenzeit von nunmehr 68 Minuten
beraten werden die weiteren
Tagesordnungspunkte der cdu/csu-fraktion
am heutigen Tag sollen entsprechend
vorrücken wobei der Tagesordnungspunkt
20 nun mit einer geänderten debattenzeit
von 39 Minuten beraten werden soll
der zunächst ohne Aussprache vorgesehene
Zusatzpunkt drei Buchstabe c soll nun im
Anschluss an top 19 mit einer Debatte
von 26 Minuten beraten werden
Tagesordnungspunkt 18 soll in
verbundener Beratung mit
Tagesordnungspunkt 20 aufgerufen werden
weiter soll Tagesordnungspunkt 32
Buchstabe g im Anschluss an Zusatzpunkt
5 mit einer 39-minütigen Debatte beraten
werden schließlich ist vorgesehen
Tagesordnungspunkt 33 Buchstabe b
abzusetzen sind Sie damit einverstanden
ich sehe kein Widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen
jetzt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
bitte ich Sie um kurze Aufmerksamkeit
wir haben heute morgen auf der Tribüne
einen besonderen Gast Roman Schwarzmann
sehr geehrter Herr Schwarzmann ich freue
mich dass Sie den beschwerlichen aber
auch gefährlichen Weg aus Odessa
zu uns gemacht haben
sie waren selbst ein Kind als die
Deutschen
1941 in die Ukraine einfielen und sie
mit ihrer Familie ins Ghetto verfrachtet
wurden seit 30 Jahren engagieren sie
sich für die jüdischen Überlebenden der
Ghettos und Konzentrationslager in der
Ukraine und ganz besonders in ihrer
Heimatstadt
und sie setzen sich mit aller Kraft
dafür ein dass die Opfer des Holocaust
nicht vergessen werden dass ihre
Geschichten weitergetragen werden und
ihrer in Würde gedacht werden ich danke
Ihnen für dieses große und wichtige
Engagement es ist uns eine Ehre Sie
heute hier im Deutschen Bundestag
begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
die Erinnerung an das
Menschheitsverbrechen der Shoa ist und
bleibt unerlässlich das ist Teil der
historischen Verantwortung Deutschlands
etwa anderthalb Millionen Jüdin und
Juden wurden in der Ukraine ermordet
mehr als 2000 Tatorte des Massenmordes
liegen auf dem Gebiet der heutigen
Ukraine jüdische Frauen Männer und
Kinder wurden zusammengetrieben sie
wurden erschossen wie in der Schlucht
vom barbinar oder verbrannt in Odessa
auch
Mario Pohl oder luhansk waren Tatorte
des Verbrechens Ortsnamen die viele von
uns in Deutschland erst seit einigen
Monaten kennen seit Russlands Überfall
auf die Ukraine der russische Präsident
begründet den völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine mit der Lüge einer
angeblich notwendigen Entnazifizierung
damit
missbraucht der in perfider Weise die
Geschichte des deutschen
Vernichtungskrieges gegen die
Sowjetunion und des Völkermordes an den
Juden Europas Millionen haben ihre
Heimat verlassen auf der Flucht vor Tod
und Gewalt ungezählte tausende sind
diesem Krieg bereits zum Opfer gefallen
darunter Überlebende des Holocaust wie
Boris romanschenko der das KZ Buchenwald
überlebte und dem dieses Haus im März
gedachte unter den vielen Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainern die bei uns Zuflucht
gefunden haben sind jüdische Kinder und
pflegebedürftige Holocaust Überlebende
sie können dank der gemeinsamen
Initiative jüdischer Organisationen in
der Ukraine und in Deutschland
evakuiert werden im Namen des ganzen
Hauses danke ich allen die diese
Rettungsaktion durch ihr Engagement
möglich gemacht haben lieber Roman
lieber Roman Schwarzmann wir stehen an
der Seite der Ukrainerin und Ukrainer
unser Ziel ist der Frieden in Freiheit
vielen Dank dass Sie heute bei uns sind
[Applaus]
nun ist es wie immer wir steigen in die
Tagesordnung ein
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 7
die Abgabe einer Regierungserklärung
durch den Bundeskanzler zum Europäischen
Rat am 20 und 21 Oktober
2022 für die Aussprache im Anschluss an
die Regierungserklärung wurde eine Dauer
von 90 Minuten vereinbart
das Wort hat zur Abgabe der
Regierungserklärung der Bundeskanzler
Herr Olaf Scholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
der brutale Krieg in der Ukraine Putins
rücksichtsloser Einsatz von Hunger und
Energie als Waffe die enormen
Preissteigerung hier bei uns und
weltweit Deutschland und Europa gehen
durch Bewährungsproben wie wir sie seit
Jahrzehnten nicht erlebt haben
Bewährungsproben die Putin uns mit
seinem imperialistischen Angriffskrieg
aufgezwungen hat
der Krieg setzt menschliche Schwäche
voraus und gegen sie ist der gerichtet
schreibt Carl von klausewitz
Putin handelt danach
man zieht die Ukraine mit Terror er
droht der Welt unverhohlen und
vollkommen verantwortungslos mit dem
Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen er will Angst
sehen Spalten und einschüchtern er
spekuliert auf unsere Schwäche
aber er irrt sich wir sind nicht schwach
unser Land steht zusammen Europa steht
zusammen und zeigt Solidarität
untereinander und mit der Ukraine unsere
weltweiten Allianzen sind stark und
lebendig wie nie putin wird seine
Kriegsziele nicht erreichen
als Putin den Krieg im Februar begann
haben manche gemutmaßt in wenigen Tagen
ist die Ukraine besiegt auch Putin
selbst hat das geglaubt
nun es ist anders gekommen es ist anders
gekommen weil die Ukraine und Ukraine
ihr Land so tapfer verteidigen und der
hohen schmerzhaften
Opfern befreien es ist anders gekommen
aber auch deshalb weil die Partner der
Ukraine darunter auch wir das Land
unterstützt haben politisch finanziell
humanitär und mit Waffen
Artillerie und Luftabwehr ist genau das
was die Ukraine besonders dringend
braucht und genau das liefern wir
moderne Panzerhaubitzen und mehrfach
Raketenwerfer zum Beispiel den
panzerringtausch mit Tschechien der
Slowakei Griechenland und Slowenien hat
manch einer auch in diesem Haus als
rohrkrippierer kritisiert inzwischen ist
klar auf diese Weise bekommt die Ukraine
rund 100 Panzer mit denen ihre Soldaten
sofort umgehen können
als eines der ersten Länder haben wir
der Ukraine Anfang Juni moderne
luftverteidigungssysteme zugesagt ein
erstes davon haben wir letzte Woche an
unsere ukrainischen Freunde übergeben
früher als ursprünglich geplant drei
weitere werden so schnell wie es geht
folgen
wir haben fliegerabwehrraketen geliefert
so wie Gepard Panzer über die es
zunächst auf fies die bringen doch
nichts dafür gebe es nicht mal genügend
Munition heute sehen wir welchen
Unterschied sie ausmachen
wie überlebenswichtig unsere
Unterstützung ist das zeigen die
brutalen russischen Raketen und
Drohnenangriffe auf zivile Ziele die wir
in den vergangenen zwei Wochen erlebt
haben wahllos fallen ihnen Frauen Männer
und Kinder zum Opfer
ja selbst diejenigen die wie Sie sehr
geehrter Herr Schwarzmann den Terror und
die Verfolgung durch die
Nationalsozialisten überlebt haben
müssen erneut um ihr Leben fürchten dass
Sie heute hier unser Gast sind ehrt und
sehr
wir lassen auch die jüngsten Eskalation
moskauz nicht unbeantwortet mit einem
weiteren Sanktionspaket haben wir als EU
den Druck auf die russische Regierung
noch einmal erhöht bei diesem Kurs
bleibt es so lange Russland seinen
brutalen Angriffskrieg fortsetzt und
auch im Kreis der G7 Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben wir vergangene
Woche gemeinsam mit Präsident selenski
bekräftigt bewusste Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung sind Kriegsverbrechen
um es klar zu sagen auch eine solche
Taktik der verbrannten Erde wird
Russland nicht helfen den Krieg zu
gewinnen sie stärkt nur die
Entschlossenheit und den
Durchhaltewillen der Ukraine und ihrer
Partner
am Ende ist Russlands Bomben und Raketen
Terror eine Verzweiflungstat genauso wie
die Mobilisierung russischer Männer für
den Krieg
damit ist der Krieg endgültig im Herzen
der russischen Gesellschaft angekommen
in den Familien und auf der Straße
hunderttausende Russen entziehen sich
der Rekrutierung viele verlassen das
Land all die Lügen und Propaganda das
Gerede von
spezialoperationen und schnellen Siegen
alles nur Fassade wie ein Podium
die Ukraine wird sich erfolgreich
verteidigen und wir werden sie
unterstützen solange wie das
erforderlich ist
Putin hat geglaubt uns Europäer Spalten
zu können dort er hat das Gegenteil
erreicht
vor einigen Tagen beim Gründungstreffen
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft haben sich 44 europäische
Staaten und die eu-institution zu dem
Grundsatz bekannt das Grenzen nicht mit
Gewalt verändert werden dürfen
niemand von uns und auch kein anderes
zivilisiertes Land der Welt akzeptiert
die fadenscheinigen Versuche Russlands
sich Teile der Ukraine unter den Nagel
zu reißen die illegalen scheinreferenten
im donetts gluhhans Cherson und
saporicia waren eine einzige Phase ihre
Ergebnisse sind null und nichtig
das müsste eigentlich auch die russische
Führung begreifen wenn sie sich das
Ergebnis der Abstimmung in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen letzte Woche anschaut
Nordkorea Syrien Nicaragua und Belarus
das waren die einzigen vier Länder die
mit Russland gestimmt haben
143 Staaten haben sich dagegen klar zur
Souveränität und zur territorialen
Integrität der Ukraine bekannt sogar
noch etwas mehr als bei den Abstimmungen
im März nach Ausbruch des Krieges
zugleich stellen sich viele die Frage
wie Putins irrsinniger Krieg beendet
werden könnte am meisten jedoch sehen
sich wohl die ukraineren Ukrainer selbst
nach Frieden
Präsident selenski ist Bereitschaft zu
einem gerechten Frieden ist daher kaum
hoch genug einzuschätzen im engen
Kontakt mit unseren Freunden in Kiew
haben wir als G7 erst vor wenigen Tagen
erklärt was es hierzu aus unserer Sicht
Bedarf
gerecht bedeutet dass es sich nicht um
ein diktatfrieden handelt sondern dass
die Souveränität die territoriale
Integrität und auch die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Ukraine
gewährleistet sind heute und in Zukunft
unsere Bereitschaft der Ukraine mit
Blick auf eine tragfähige Friedenslösung
langfristige sicherheitszusage zu geben
haben wir ebenfalls als G7 erneut
bekräftigt
auch beim heute beginnenden Europäischen
Rat werden wir über die weitere
Unterstützung der Ukraine beraten die
gute Nachricht ist der Finanzbedarf Kias
bis Jahresende ist praktisch gedeckt die
EU und die G7 spielen dabei eine
entscheidende Rolle doch der Krieg und
seine Folgen werden uns noch auf viele
Jahre beschäftigen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir heute
schon überlegen wie wir die Ukraine in
den kommenden Jahren beim Wiederaufbau
unterstützen wer die Bilder aus den von
Russland befreiten ukrainischen Städten
und Dörfern sieht der versteht
das wird eine Generationenaufgabe bei
der die gesamte zivilisierte
Staatengemeinschaft ihre Kräfte bündeln
muss
deshalb haben Ursula von der Leyen und
ich als Präsident der G7 der
wirtschaftsstarken Demokratien kluge
Köpfe aus Wissenschaft Wirtschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft für den 25 Oktober
nach Berlin eingeladen
bei einer internationalen
Expertenkonferenz wenn Sie Ihre
Vorschläge für einen langfristigen
verlässlichen und transparenten
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine zusammenführen
und so Input liefern für ein
internationalen maßschaltplan für die
Ukraine
europäische und internationale
Koordinierung brauchen wir auch bei der
militärischen Unterstützung der Ukraine
diesen Vorschlag hatte ich bei meiner
Rede an der Prager Karls-Universität
Ente August gemacht seither ist diese
Idee weiter vorangekommen am Montag
haben sich die EU-Außenminister auf eine
neue ausbildungsmission für ca 15.000
ukrainische Soldaten und Soldaten hier
in der EU geeinigt eines der beiden
Hauptquartiere wird sich in Deutschland
befinden bis zum Frühjahr werden wir
eine vollständige Brigade mit bis zu
5.000 Soldaten ausbilden damit
unterstreichen wir unsere Bereitschaft
und dauerhaft am Aufbau starker
ukrainischer Streitkräfte zu beteiligen
Hand in Hand mit unseren Partnern
im Licht der Zeitenwende stellen wir
auch unser Land sicherheitspolitisch neu
auf
dafür steht das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr dafür steht die
Refokussierung unser Streitkräfte auf
die Landes- und bündnisverteidigung und
die Übernahme größerer Verantwortung an
der östlichen Flanke der Allianz dafür
steht die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
an der wir intensiv arbeiten und der
verstehen die Vorschläge zur
sicherheitszusammenarbeit in Europa die
ich in meiner Rede in Prag skizziert
habe
und ich freue mich dass die Idee einer
engeren europäischen Kooperation bei der
Luft Verteidigung so schnell von 14
europäischen Ländern aufgegriffen wurde
die dabei mit uns zusammenarbeiten
wollen das ist genau die Art von
seinergie die Art von
klugerarbeitsteilung wie wir sie für die
Sicherheit Europas jetzt brauchen
Russlands Krieg hat aber nicht nur
tiefgreifende Folgen für Europa weltweit
hat er für Engpässe bei Nahrungsmitteln
und Dünger gesorgt mit fatalen Folgen
830 Millionen mehr als jeder zehnte
Weltbürger hat laut aktuellen Zahlen
nicht genug zu essen
Putin nimmt das nicht nur in Kauf er
nutzt Hunger als Waffe
wir müssen uns auch diese
Bewährungsprobe stellen das ist eine
Frage der Humanität das ist aber auch
eine Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit
wenn wir wollen dass die Länder Afrikas
Asiens Lateinamerikas und der Karibik
uns auch künftig dabei unterstützen das
Völkerrecht gegen Aggressionen wie die
russische zu verteidigen dann ist es nur
recht und billig dass wir auch Ihre
Sorgen im Umgang mit den Folgen des
russischen Krieges ernst nehmen
in der Europäischen Union haben wir
dafür sehr früh damit begonnen
Alternative exportwege für ukrainisches
Getreide aufzubauen per Bahnen oder per
Schiff zum Beispiel über die Donau wir
haben die Vereinten Nationen und die
Türkei in den Verhandlungen über eine
Öffnung des Seewegs im Schwarzen Meer
unterstützt und wir greifen Ländern
weltweit unter die Arme die mit Hunger
Ernte Ausfällen und steigenden Preisen
für Brot und andere Grundnahrungsmittel
zu kämpfen haben
eines der zentralen Ziele unserer
g7-präsidentschaft war die Gründung
eines Bündnisses für globale
Ernährungssicherheit ich bin froh dass
uns das gelungen ist
und mit den diesjährigen Zusagen der G7
in Höhe von 14 Milliarden Dollar haben
wir zunächst zumindest eine Chance eine
globale
Hungerkatastrophe abzuwenden
meine Damen und Herren auch Energie
setzt putinen als Waffe ein lange vor
der Zerstörung der nordstream Pipelines
in der Ostsee hat Russland bereits seine
Lieferung durch Nord Stream 1
eingestellt ohne nachvollziehbaren Grund
und deshalb
dieses Russland unter Putin ist kein
zuverlässiger Handelspartner mehr
für uns und für die gesamte Welt
bedeutet das auf dem Weltmarkt fehlt ein
Großteil der 55 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Gast die Russland zuletzt durch
Pipelines nach Europa geliefert hat
Putin hat gehofft uns mit dem Abdrehen
des gasthahns erpressen zu können
doch auch da hat er sich verrechnet
denn Europa steht zusammen und auch wir
als Land haben mit den Maßnahmen der
vergangenen Wochen und Monate
sichergestellt dass wir voll Zuversicht
sagen können gemeinsam kommen wir wohl
durch diesen Winter
in Windeseile haben wir alternative
importstrukturen aufgebaut die ersten
flüssigkeitsterminals in Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel gehen zum Jahreswechsel ans
Netz auch erste Lieferung über Lupinen
können dann möglicherweise erfolgen
weitere Terminals werden im Laufe des
kommenden Jahres hinzukommen
seit einer Woche fließt erstmals
überhaupt Gas aus Frankreich zu uns auch
die Kapazitäten an dem westeuropäischen
Häfen in den Niederlanden und Belgien
nutzen wir um zusätzliches Gast zu
beschaffen
verlässliche Partner wie Norwegen haben
ihre Lieferungen an uns erhöht mit den
USA und Ländern der arabischen Halbinsel
haben wir neue Lieferverträge
abgeschlossen weitere sind in
Vorbereitung
mit all diesen Maßnahmen haben wir
geschafft unsere Speicher in Deutschland
Europa rechtzeitig vor dem Winter zu
füllen anders als übrigens im Vorjahr
der den Füllstand von 95 Prozent den wir
in Deutschland zum ersten November
erreichen wollten haben wir schon
unterschritt überschritten das ist eine
große Leistung
wir haben entschieden dass wir
Kohlekraftwerke wieder ans Netz nehmen
erst in diesen Tagen sind fünf weitere
braunkohlekraftwerksblöcke in der
Lausitz und im Rheinischen Revier
hinzugekommen als zeitlich begrenzte
aber notwendige Notfallmaßnahme
Notfallmaßnahme denn wir stehen weiter
fest zu unseren erklärten Klimazielen
wir sorgen dafür dass wir alle drei noch
laufenden Atomkraftwerke den gesamten
Winterland nutzen können so hat es das
Kabinett gestern auf den Weg gebracht
und schließlich haben Unternehmen den
Umstieg von Gast auf andere
Energiequellen erleichtert für Switch
leitet das Stichwort
das alles steckt Deutschlands und
Europas Energiesicherheit
hinzu kommen die sparanstrengung vieler
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auch
zahlreiche Unternehmen ich bin dafür
außerordentlich dankbar
gemeinsam wollen wir unseren
gastverbrauch um 20% senken denn jede
Kilowattstunde die wir einsparen stärkt
unsere Energiesicherheit
und ich bin froh
und ich bin froh dass es uns gelungen
zur auf europäischer Ebene auf ein
einspeziel von 15 Prozent beim
gastverbrauch zu einigen das ist ein
starkes Signal europäischer Solidarität
gerade auch gegenüber unserem Land das
bislang ganz besonders von russischem
Gas abhängig war
abhängig war wohlgemerkt denn wir haben
uns aus der Abhängigkeit befreit und
gehen zugleich gut vorbereitet in den
kommenden Winter
und noch etwas möchte ich erwähnen wenn
wir über Energiesicherheit reden unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden die Bundespolizei
die Dienste des Bundeskriminalamt das
PSI tun alles um gemeinsam mit den
Betreibern unsere kritischen
Infrastrukturen zu schützen auch mit den
Partnern in der NATO in der Europäischen
Union sind wir dazu intensivem
Abstimmung mit Schweden und Dänemark
stimmen wir uns eng bei der Aufklärung
des sabotageakts gegen die beiden
nordstream Pipelines ab
auf sie zeigen Marine und Bundespolizei
mit allen verfügbaren Kräften und
Schiffen Präsenz und noch in diesem Jahr
wollen wir Eckpunkte beschließen für ein
dachgesetz zum besseren Schutz
kritischer Infrastrukturen
wir wissen absolute Sicherheit kann es
angesichts der Größe und Komplexität
kritischer Infrastrukturen nicht geben
aber auch hier gilt wir sorgen vor und
vor allem wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern
meine Damen und Herren die
Energiesicherheit ist das eine die viel
zu hohen Energiepreise sind eine andere
große Bewährungsprobe für unser Land und
für Europa
keine Frage die Preise für Strom und
Wärme für Gas Öl und Kohle müssen runter
und zwar auf einen für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und für unsere Unternehmen
verträgliches Maß auch das wird zu Recht
Thema sein beim Europäischen Rat heute
und morgen in Brüssel
wir haben beschlossen hier in
Deutschland eine strompreisbremse
einzuführen analog zu Entscheidungen auf
europäischer Ebene an der Umsetzung
arbeiten wir aktuell mit Hochdruck Ziel
ist Bürgern und Bürger so rasch wie
möglich für ein grundkontingent von
Strom zu entlasten
wir sind dabei den europäischen Weg
gegangen und haben in weniger Wochen
Mehrheiten in Europa zustande bekommen
das zeigt die EU ist in diesen Fragen
handlungsfähig und die Bundesregierung
wird immer darauf achten diese
europäische Handlungsfähigkeit zu
stärken
bei den Preisen für Gast und Wärme ist
das Ganze komplizierter denn der
Gaspreis wird von Knappheiten auf dem
Weltmarkt bestimmt
aber auch hier sind wir auf europäischer
Ebene schon weit gekommen so werden wir
beim Europäischen Rat heute darüber
sprechen unsere Nachfrage zu bündeln
ich bin der Europäischen Kommission
daher dankbar für Ihre Vorschläge
Einkaufsgemeinschaften europäischer
Unternehmen möglich zu machen die
gemeinsamen Gast kaufen können richtig
ist auch ein Teil der Kapazität der
europäischen gastspeicher im nächsten
Jahr gemeinsam zu befüllen
mit dem Modell Trading hat Europe haben
wir gezeigt wie das gehen kann
auch über die Entwicklung eines
ergänzenden gaspreisindexes zum TTF
werden wir uns Gedanken machen der
Bezugspunkt sein kann für künftige
gastimport Verträge
das beste Mittel
gegen ein zu knappes Angebot aber bleibt
der schnelle Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien die Kommission hat dazu bereits
Vorschläge für einfache
Planungsverfahren gemacht das sollte nun
auch für die großen Übertragungsnetze
geschehen auch dafür werde ich mich beim
Europäischen Rat stark machen
um die Ausfallenden russischen
gastliefern zu ersetzen müssen wir
außerdem mit Ländern zusammenarbeiten
indem die Möglichkeit zu Erschließung
neuer gastfelder besteht natürlich im
Rahmen unserer Verpflichtung aus dem
Pariser Klimaabkommen
wir werden auch darüber sprechen wie wir
mit Preisspitzen umgehen die Vorschläge
der Kommission dazu schauen wir uns sehr
genau an
ein politisch gesetzter preisdeckel
wirkt aber immer das Risiko dass die
Produzenten ihr Gast dann anderswo
verkaufen und wir Europäer am Ende nicht
mehr Gas bekommen sondern weniger
deshalb muss ich die EU mit anderen
gastkonsumenten etwa mit Japan und Korea
eng abstimmen damit wir uns nicht
gegenseitig Konkurrenz machen und
zugleich sprechen wir auch mit den
Produzenten über einen angemessenen
Preis
ich bin überzeugt Länder wie die USA
Kanada oder Norwegen dem gemeinsam mit
uns solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen haben ein Interesse daran dass
Energie in Europa nicht unbezahlbar wird
auch im g7-kreis sprechen wir darüber
schließlich wurde die G7
bzw damals noch die Gesetze als Antwort
auf die erste Ölkrise der 70er Jahre und
die Zusammenbruch des
breitenwood-systems gegründet damals ist
es in diesem Rahmen gelungen die Welt
gemeinsam zurück auf einen Wachstumspfad
zu führen und das ist auch mein Ziel als
G7 Vorsitzender heute
parallel nutzen wir natürlich auch die
Möglichkeiten die wir als
Volkswirtschaft haben um die gast- und
Wärmepreise auf einen verträgliches Maß
zu senken dem dient der wirtschaftliche
Abwehrschirm von bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro der unter anderem die
gaspreisbremse beinhaltet
eine Kommission aus Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftlern
arbeitgebervertretern Gewerkschaften
Stadtwerke und Energieversorgern hat uns
Anfang letzter Woche ein klugen
Vorschlag gemacht wie wir die
Preissteigerung für Gast und Fernwärme
stark begrenzen können
die vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen haben
eines gemeinsam sie halten Energie
bezahlbar wirken schnell und Hebel
zugleich einspar-
wir setzen diesen Vorschlag nun um
spätestens im März nächsten Jahres
erhalten alle Bürger und Bürger mit Gast
oder Fernwärme ein vergünstigtes
basiskontingent und um schon früher für
Entlastung zu sorgen hat die Kommission
und empfohlen dass die Versorger das
Geld für Abschlagszahlung im Dezember
vom Staat erhalten
auch Unternehmen kleine und große werden
gezielt entlastet und deshalb können wir
heute sagen niemand keine Familie keine
Rentnerin kein Student und auch kein
Unternehmen soll Angst haben vor den
Preisen für Strom Gas oder Fernwärme
überfordert zu werden
unseren Abwehrschirm haben wir bewusst
auf zweieinhalb Jahre angelegt um auch
für den nächsten Winter gewappnet zu
sein auf diesen Zeitraum gerechnet
entsprechen die 200 Milliarden Euro um
die zwei Prozent unseres
Bruttoinlandsprodukts das liegt in der
Größenordnung der Pakete die in diesem
Jahr auch anders wo in Europa geschnürt
wurden und werden in Frankreich in
Italien oder in Spanien zum Beispiel
die Europäische Union verfügt zudem über
genügend finanzielle Durchschlagskraft
um sich dieser Kriege entgegenzustellen
aus der Aufbau und resilienzfassilität
die wir während der corona-pandemie
gemeinsam beschlossen haben ist bislang
erst ein Fünftel ausgezahlt hier stehen
also noch über 600 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung die unsere Volkswirtschaften
stärken und für den Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien genutzt werden können
dabei hilft uns auch die Einigung zur
Finanzierung von Repower EU die die
europäischen Finanzminister vor kurzem
erzielt haben damit wird ein
dreistelliger Milliardenbetrag aus den
Mitteln des Instruments next generation
EU genutzt und aufgestockt um uns
unabhängig zu machen von fossiler
Energie ich bin bereit zu schauen wie
wir diese und andere vorhandene Mittel
in der aktuellen Krise noch effizienter
einsetzen können
meine Damen und Herren diese europäische
Solidarität sorgt dafür dass die
Europäische Union Putins Energie
Erpressung standhält
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eines
dürfen wir aber über all die
Bewährungsproben für die uns Putins
Angriffskrieg gestellt hat nicht aus den
Augen verlieren unser Ziel aus der
Nutzung fossiler Ressourcen auszusteigen
der schnelle Ausbau erneuerbare Energien
und der Netze sowie mehr
Energieeffizienz sind die beste
Strategie damit unsere Energieversorgung
sicher bleibt und wieder bezahlbar wird
jedes Windrad an Land oder auf See jede
Photovoltaikanlage macht uns ein Stück
unabhängiger von teurem Gast oder Öl
der Umbau des Energiesektors die
Transformation unserer Industrie die
Modernisierung unserer Gebäude der
Ausbau der Bahnung des Nahverkehrs der
Hochlauf der Elektromobilität und der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft das sind daher die
zentralen Aufgaben dieses Jahrzehnts
und die Weichen dafür sind gestellt wir
haben die umfassendste Novelle des EEG
des letzten Jahrzehnts verabschiedet wir
beschleunigen den Ausbau der Offshore
Windkraft im Februar kommenden Jahres
wird das Windenergie an Landgesetz in
Kraft treten das 2% der Fläche unseres
Landes für die Windkraft zur Verfügung
stellt noch im Herbst wollen wir ein
weiteres Paket zur
planungsbeschleunigung beschließen
denn was ich Anfang dieses Jahres
versprochen habe das halten wir ein alle
Regeln alle wichtigen Gesetze die es
braucht damit Deutschland seine
Klimaziele erreicht die stehen bis zum
Jahresende
auch auf EU-Ebene halten wir Kurs wir
wollen in den kommenden Monaten eine
endgültige Einigung auf das fit for
fifty five Paket herbeiführen als
Booster für den internationalen
Klimaschutz beim Anstehen der
Europäischen Rat werden wir unsere
Position für die anstehende
Weltklimakonferenz in Sharm el Sheikh
abstimmen die russische Aggression und
ihre Folgen dürfen nicht zu einer
weltweiten Renaissance der Kohle führen
deshalb werden wir klare Angebote machen
damit auch Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländer den Weg in Richtung
eines klimaneutralen Energiesektors
geschlossen entschlossen gehen und wir
werden den Staaten entschlossen helfen
die schon heute besonders unter den
Folgen des Klimawandels leiden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bewährungsproben unserer Zeit erfordern
neues Denken und mutiges Handeln von
jedem von uns
im Eiltempo und oft unter größten
Handlungsdruck haben wir in den
vergangenen Monaten weitreichende
zukunftsweisende Entscheidungen
getroffen für Europa für unser Land für
seine Bürger und Bürger
dabei haben wir miteinander immer wieder
um den besten Weg gerungen und werden
das auch weiterhin tun denn auch das ist
wichtig
in einer Autokratie wie Russland ist das
Ziel größtmögliche Uniformität
Kreativität und Widerspruch werden
bestraft mutige Oppositionelle
verschwinden auf Jahre in Gefängnissen
oder werden in den Ziel gezwungen nicht
zuletzt das Schicksal einiger der
diesjährigen Friedensnobelpreisträger
erinnert uns an diese Schande
in Demokratien wie unserer aber liefern
unsere Debatten liefern freie Medien und
öffentliche Kritik immer wieder Anstöße
für Veränderung und den Fortschritt
darin liegt die Stärke offener
Gesellschaften darin liegt die Kraft der
Demokratie
diese Kraft diese Stärke meine Damen und
Herren unterschätzen Putin und seine
Gefolgsleute auf dramatische Weise und
deshalb bin ich sicherer denn je
Putins Kriegskurs gegen die Ukraine und
die gesamte freie Welt wird scheitern
eigentlich ist es schon längst
die Ukraine Deutschland und Europa aber
werden gestärkt aus diesen
Bewährungsproben hervorgehen geeinter
und unabhängiger als zuvor schönen Dank
ja der Bundeskanzler verharrte noch kurz
am Pult hat sich verneigt viel Applaus
aus dem ampelfraktionen für diese
Regierungserklärung von Olaf Scholz 30
Minuten hat er hier den großen Bogen
gespannt gleich am Anfang hat er gesagt
Putin spekuliert auf unsere Schwäche
aber er irrt sich Putin wird seine
Kriegsziele nicht erreichen er hat dann
die Solidarität der Europäer gelobt auf
dem europäischen Gipfel geschaut und
auch gesagt wenn Geld gebraucht wird in
dem Corona Fond sind noch 600 Milliarden
Euro die man verwenden kann dann hatte
er im hinteren Teil den
innenpolitischeren Teil sage ich mal
darauf hingewiesen dass diese
Bundesregierung alle Gesetze die
notwendig sind bis zum Jahresende
abschließen wird und der erste Redner
nach dieser Regierungserklärung ist der
Oppositionschef Friedrich Merz
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
angesichts des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine und
der folgen die dieser Krieg mittlerweile
auch für unser Land hat steht die
Europäische Union in diesen Wochen und
Monaten möglicherweise vor der größten
Bewährungsprobe ihrer Geschichte
wir können daher alle nur hoffen dass
die 27 Staats- und Regierungschefs heute
und morgen in Brüssel zu guten und
tragfähigen Lösungen kommen Herr
Bundeskanzler wir wünschen Ihnen und
Ihren amtskolleginnen und Amtskollegen
in der Europäischen Union bei den
anstehenden Beratungen jeden möglichen
Erfolg
europa braucht diesen Erfolg
unser Land deutschland braucht diesen
Erfolg vor allem aber die Menschen die
privaten Haushalte und die vielen
Unternehmen die kleinen die mittleren
und die großen brauchen jetzt schnelle
und wirksame Hilfe
es sollte dabei auch klar sein welche
Aufgaben die Europäische Union übernimmt
was sie leisten kann und muss was Europa
jetzt ausdrücklich nicht tun sollte und
was zwingend in der Verantwortung und
der Zuständigkeit der Mitgliedstaaten
bleiben muss
lassen Sie mich dazu etwas ausführlicher
sprechen meine Damen und Herren die
notwendigen Sanktionen gegen Russland
und sie haben Bundeskanzler darüber
ausführlich gesprochen gehen nur
gemeinsam und ja hat Europa in der Tat
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten eine
große Geschlossenheit und eine große
Entschlossenheit gezeigt Europa hat
diese Bewährungsprobe bestanden auch in
enger Abstimmung und Kooperation mit
anderen vor allem mit den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika
auch die finanziellen und humanitären
Hilfen für die Ukraine den
weitgehend jedenfalls nur gemeinsam auch
hier hat die Europäische Union
wirkungsvoll und zielführend geholfen
es wäre schließlich wünschenswert
gewesen meine Damen und Herren wenn auch
die militärische Hilfe für die
Europäische Union
europäisch abgestimmt und koordiniert
vorgenommen worden wäre und ich
wiederhole von dieser Stelle aus zum
wiederholten Male wir hätten es für
richtig gehalten wenn die Ukraine wenn
die ukrainische Armee auch mit
Schützenpanzern und Kampfpanzern
westlicher Bauart ausgestattet worden
wäre abgestimmt in der Europäischen
Union so wie viele Mitgliedstaaten es
befürworten
so wie eine große Zahl von Kolleginnen
und Kollegen insbesondere aus der grünen
Fraktion und aus der FDP-Fraktion ist
befürworten so wie wir es befürworten
dieser Krieg wäre dann möglicherweise
schneller zu Ende gewesen
und nun zu den Energiepreisen Herr
Bundeskanzler aus ihrer
Regierungserklärung können die zuhören
und Zuhörer heute morgen die Betroffenen
privaten Haushalte die Unternehmen in
Deutschland und darüber hinaus kaum
etwas Konkretes entnehmen wann ihnen
denn nun endlich geholfen wird
sie haben auch wenig und gar nichts
gesagt zum Arbeitsprogramm der
Kommission das gestern vorgelegt worden
ist meine Damen und Herren bei diesem
Arbeitsprogramm muss man den Eindruck
gewinnen als ob bis auf eine einzige
Ausnahme und das ist die sogenannte
Chemikalien Rechtsprechung oder
rechtssitzung bis auf eine Ausnahme in
allen anderen Bereichen in dieser
Europäischen Kommission der Apparat
weiter läuft und läuft und läuft und
jede Woche und jeden Monat neue
Richtlinien neue Verordnungen neue
Belastungen vor allem für die
Unternehmen in Europa auslöst meine
Damen und Herren das ist nein wir haben
Ihnen den konkreten Vorschlag gemacht
und sie haben es ja aufgenommen für das
nationale Programm ein
belastungsmoratorium warum sprechen Sie
nicht auch über einen
belastungsmoratorium jetzt in der
Europäischen Union
warum lassen sie zu warum befördert ihre
Regierung dass auch in der Europäischen
Kommission von Woche zu Woche weitere
Vorschläge und Belastungen für die
Unternehmen gemacht werden bis hin zu
einer
csr-richtlinie die die Berichtspflichten
der Unternehmen gerade jetzt in dieser
Krise endgültig zu einem bürokratischen
Monstrum werden lassen wir brauchen
jetzt ein belastungsmoratorium für die
Unternehmen in der Europäischen Union
und damit auch in Deutschland
und dann bleiben tatsächlich zahlreiche
Aufgaben in der nationalen Verantwortung
meine Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler
sie fahren in dieser Hinsicht morgen
heute und morgen nach Brüssel nicht
gerade mit gutem Vorbild im Gegenteil
Deutschland dürfte in Brüssel bewertet
werden als das Land in Europa dessen
Regierung in den letzten Monaten am
heftigsten gestritten und mit am
wenigsten erreicht hat bei der
Entlastung der privaten Haushalte und
der Unternehmen
dieser Krieg
dauert in wenigen Tagen jetzt acht
Monate und wenn man hört was sie auch
auf verbandstagungen gerade vor wenigen
Tagen hier in Berlin gesagt haben dann
wissen Sie ja schon sehr viel länger
welche Folgen dieser Krieg
möglicherweise haben kann sie haben hier
in Berlin vor wenigen Tagen gesagt ich
war mir immer sicher dass er putin war
gemeint das tun würde nämlich Energie
als Waffe einzusetzen und dann sagen Sie
das war glaube ich zu einer Zeit als die
allermeisten das nicht für
wahrscheinlich gehalten haben aber ich
habe es für möglich gehalten sie nehmen
Bezug auf eine Besprechung mit
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern im
Bundeskanzleramt im dezember 2021 ich
war mir immer sicher dass er das tun
würde Herr Bundeskanzler wenn sie sich
im dezember 2021 schon sicher waren dass
er das tun würde warum haben sie dann
eigentlich bis die Kriegsbeginn an
nordstream 2 festgehalten und das zu
einem privatwirtschaftlichen Projekt
erklärt und warum haben Sie eigentlich
von dieser klugen Erkenntnis nicht ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Europäischen Union in Kenntnis gesetzt
dass man schon im Dezember 2021 hätte an
Maßnahmen denken müssen zur Bewältigung
dieser Krise
sie haben zu Beginn sie haben zu Beginn
ihrer
Regierungserklärung klausewitz zitiert
Herr Bundeskanzler von Clausewitz stammt
auch der schöne Satz aus dem Wissen muss
ein können werden das hätten wir von
Ihnen auch erwartet
sie haben sie haben eine
gaskommission um Vorschläge gebeten zur
Dämpfung der Gaspreise und zur Lösung
dieses Problems diese Vorschläge liegen
nun seit Anfang der letzten Woche vor
wir haben zwei Sitzungswochen des
Deutschen Bundestages in dieser und in
der letzten sie haben nicht einen
einzigen Vorschlag unterbreitet heute
welche Schlussfolgerungen denn aus
dieser gaskommission gezogen werden
sollen zur Lösung des Problems bei der
Gasbeschaffung und bei den Gaspreis
es bleibt es bleibt völlig offen was
denn diejenigen privaten Haushalte die
noch mit Öl heizen oder die zum Beispiel
gerade frisch angeschafft haben eine
Pelletheizung wie diese halt wie dieser
Haushalte denn konkret entlastet werden
sollen damit kein Missverständnis
entsteht wir befürworten hier
weitestgehend gemeinsame europäische
Wege aber es gibt Verantwortungen im
nationalen Zusammenhang der sie
nachkommen müssen und die die
Europäische Union überhaupt nicht
übernehmen kann diese Fragen gehören
dazu und diese Fragen bedürfen der
Beantwortung im Deutschen Bundestag und
nicht auf der Ebene des Europäischen
Rates
und wenn sie jetzt als einziges Datum
nennen wo die privaten Haushalte und die
Unternehmen Entlastung erwarten dürfen
das Frühjahr 2023 dann kann ich Ihnen
nur sagen der Bundeskanzler Winterreifen
muss man im Oktober aufziehen und nicht
erst im Frühjahr des nächsten Jahres
jetzt brauchen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen in Deutschland eine klare
Perspektive jetzt brauchen die Menschen
und die Unternehmen in Deutschland eine
klare Antwort wann sie möglichst bald in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen mit
konkreter Entlastung rechnen dürfen und
deswegen will ich abschließend sagen die
besten Beschlüsse in Brüssel
bewirken überhaupt nichts wenn die
Bundesregierung in Deutschland nicht
schnell zu wirksamen Entlastungen kommt
für private Haushalte und für die
Unternehmen von denen die meisten nicht
mehr lange Zeit haben herzlichen Dank
soweit also Friedrich Merz der am Anfang
seiner Rede konzertierte das Europa
gemeinsam die Sanktionen gegen Russland
durchgesetzt habe März kritisierte aber
bei der militärischen Hilfe des die
Union ist von Anfang an für richtig
gehalten hätte Schützenpanzer oder
Kampfpanzer ein zu setzen
bei den Energiepreisen kritisierte er
das hier den Menschen immer noch nicht
geholfen ist sie wissen nicht wo sie
dran sind und gegen Ende hatte er noch
mal betont es müsste jetzt Perspektiven
geben auch für die deutsche Wirtschaft
die durch europäische Regelung nicht
ständig mehr belastet werden darf man
jetzt von den bundesgründen einer der
beiden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren von diesem
Gipfeltreffen muss ein Signal der
Geschlossenheit ausgehen und ich bin mir
sicher dass wir das auch
Geschlossenheit um unser gemeinsames
Vorgehen bei den sanktionspaketen bei
den finanziellen
humanitären und bei der militärischen
Unterstützung
deutlich zu machen zu unterstreichen und
klarzumachen dass sie das schärfste
Schwert sind gegen Putin europäische
Geschlossenheit die Geschlossenheit der
7 und der internationalen
Staatengemeinschaft sind in dieser Krise
das wichtigste von was wir haben meine
Damen und Herren und
gleichzeitig und davon bin ich davon
gehen wir aus ganz klare Signale
ausgehen
europäische und nationale Maßnahmen
gegen hohe Energiepreise werden Hand in
Hand gehen dafür machen wir uns stark
der gemeinsame Einkauf von Gas die
Senkung des Verbrauchs und die
versifizierung von Energiequellen durch
erneuerbare ein Booster für erneuerbare
Energien und auch einer übergewinnsteuer
die zur Abfederung sozialer Härten in
den Nationalstaaten und europäisch in
der unterschiedlichen Lage der Staaten
dient das werden gemeinsame Botschaften
sein und Aufträge die wir uns wechselt
seitlich erteilen und das ist gut und
wichtig so dass dieses Signal aus Europa
ausgehen wird beim Europäischen Rat
meine Damen und Herren wir verurteilen
die jüngsten massiven Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung auf die zivile
Infrastruktur in der Ukraine die
Mobilisierung in Russland die Allianz
mit was Russland die völkerrechtswidrige
Annexion der besetzten Gebiete die
Angriffe auf so viele unschuldige
Menschen
die wahnsinnige Irrationalität dieses
brutalen Angriffskrieges und das zeigt
auch dass Putin immer mehr in
bedrängnisgerät weil er führt den Krieg
jetzt so gegen die Menschen die
Zivilbevölkerung und es trifft sie alle
so grausam und hart es ist brutal das
bereitet mir und uns große Sorgen
gestern nun noch die Verhängung des
Kriegsrechts in den sogenannten
annektierten Gebieten hier sollen neue
Spannungen geschürt werden ein
vermeintlicher Angriff auch der Ukraine
auf vermeintlich russisches Territorium
dabei ist doch klar es gibt kein
russisches Kriegsrecht auf
ukrainischem Territorium meine Damen und
Herren
1100 ukrainische Orte Siedlung Dörfer
sind ohne Strom Angriffe auf Wohnhäuser
auf Krankenhäuser auf
Versorgungseinrichtungen auf Spielplätze
die
Zivilbevölkerung soll in Angst und
Schrecken versetzt werden die Menschen
leiden in dieser Situation unglaublich
und deshalb ist jede Kraftanstrengung
nötig und deshalb dürfen wir auch nicht
nachlassen in unserem Engagement
humanitär wirtschaftlich für den
Wiederaufbau für die Frage der
Beitrittsperspektive der EU und auch was
die Waffenlieferungen angeht meine Damen
und Herren jeden Tag müssen wir uns
fragen tun wir genug und was können wir
noch leisten dass es unsere Aufgabe im
europäischen Verbund
und meine Damen und Herren werden hier
einerseits die Solidarität mit der
Ukraine einfordert und mehr Solidarität
einfordert Herr Merz ich will Ihnen an
dieser Stelle sagen ich habe es an
anderer schon getan es hat weh getan
wirklich vegetan und geschmerzt und ihre
halbseidene Entschuldigung hat daran
nichts geändert dass sie in dieser
schrecklichen Situation sich so
abwertend und populistisch gegenüber
geflüchteten Menschen in der Ukraine
geäußert haben
und es ist unverzeihlich
denn kurz nach ihrer Entschuldigung
wurde weiter nachgelegt in diesem Thema
und ich finde sie sollten das überdenken
denn wir haben hier alle eine große
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen die
noch in der Ukraine sind und dort in
ihrem Land bleiben und kämpfen und
gegenüber denen die hier sind und sich
nicht sehnlicher wünschen wieder
zurückzugehen in ihrer Heimat die Suppe
droht ist und deshalb lassen Sie die
Finger davon mit dieser Methode
Populismus in dieser Art und Weise zu
arbeiten meine Damen und Herren und
wieder
und wieder haben wir gerade die
den Vorwurf gehört jetzt handelt mal
endlich
wo sind sie eigentlich in dieser
Situation wo sind sie in ihrer
Verantwortung in der größten Krise
dieses Landes und der größten Krise
Europas sich nicht in fundamental
Opposition zu verkriechen sondern
Verantwortung zu übernehmen meine Damen
und Herren
und jetzt mal kurz zum Thema diese
Regierung handelt nicht
meine Damen und Herren wir haben zwei
entlastungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
zur sozialen Abfederung die sind für
Menschen für Handwerk für Wirtschaft
eine Unterstützung und da können Sie 100
mal sagen es ist nicht der Fall es wirkt
wenn
energiepreisbremse wenn
Unterstützungsleistungen für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner für Studierende
wenn die Frage der Grundsicherung erhöht
wird und und und und und das sind alles
Maßnahmen die gezielt abfedern sollen
die sozialen Härten in diesem Land und
das ist gut und wichtig so der
der gerade geplant wird sie sollten
nicht einfach nur sagen das läuft nicht
gut machen Sie doch mal einen Vorschlag
wo sind sie denn da Griechen in ihren
Löchern und erklären jeden Tag wir
würden nicht handeln und weil sie da
vielleicht eine kleine Stütze brauchen
sage ich Ihnen mal kurz was diese
Bundesregierung gemeinsam mit Robert
Habeck ihm Verantwortlichen Ministerium
und den anderen minister:innen auf den
Weg gebracht hat die Verpflichtung zu
befüllen der Gasspeicher die Forcierung
des Netzausbaus der Ausbau der
wind-Energie der schnellere Ausbau der
lng-terminals der wasserstoffausgleich
die Anpassung der Ausschreibungen für
Wind und Solar die
effizienz-standards das
Energieeffizienzgesetz die
Abstandsregeln aufheben die alle lange
die windenergieausbau Sachen blockiert
haben dass erneuerbare Energien Gesetz
das wieder die wirtschaftsgesetz das
bundesbedarfsplanungsgesetz und
zahlreiche Verordnungen ich weiß es tut
ihnen weh wenn man das aufzählt weil
dann zeigt sich damit das konkret
gehandelt wird meine Damen und Herren
und darum geht es in dieser Krise
genau darum geht es in dieser Krise und
ich erwarte von ihnen dass sie
Verantwortung übernehmen und sie
konstruktiv in diese
Lösungssuche einbringen meine Damen und
Herren wir sind in einer schweren Krise
und dass das notwendig und lassen Sie
mich zuletzt doch sagen als bitte und
zugleich als Aufforderung denn wir
wissen was die fossile Abhängigkeit
Russlands für unser Land in dieser Krise
bedeutet wir haben in den vergangenen
Monaten gesehen was das bedeutet und wir
sollten wenn wir über China diskutieren
dringend berücksichtigen was uns die
fossile Abhängigkeit und die Zement
Abhängigkeit von Russland gekostet hat
keine Fehler in Bezug auf die
China-Politik meine Damen und Herren das
ist notwendig und da steht jetzt an
Britta Hasselmann hat vor allen Dingen
am Schluss gefordert dass die Opposition
Verantwortung übernehmen soll hat dann
eine Leistungsbilanz vorgelegt für was
der Wirtschaftsminister der grüne
Verantwortung tragen hat wie viel
Gesetze schon auf den Weg gebracht
worden sind und am Anfang hat sie gesagt
von diesem Gipfel um den es ja geht
heute und morgen in Brüssel muss den
Signal der Geschlossenheit ausgehen tut
es aber leider nicht denn
deutsch-französische Achse knirscht
gewaltig Kino
vorab den Zweige töteten Handwerkern in
Ludwigshafen gedenken die vor zwei Tagen
von einem Somalia ermordet wurden Frau
Hasselmann das schmerzt ich wünsche den
Familien und Hinterbliebenen viel Kraft
ich wünsche den verletzten schnelle
Genesung
und auch das ist mittlerweile Normalität
in Deutschland kommen wir zum
Europäischen Rat der heute und morgen in
Brüssel zusammentritt um den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und seine
Auswirkungen auf die Energiekrise und
die Wirtschaften Europa behandelt so ist
ja auch der Titel einerseits scheint die
Brisanz einer Energiekrise in den Köpfen
angekommen zu sein andererseits wechselt
man hier wieder Ursache und Wirkung eine
Antwort auf die Krise soll jedenfalls
der sogenannte
gaspreisdeckel sein so hören wir es und
so lesen wir es jedoch bleiben hier mehr
Fragen offen kann die Energie und
Versorgungssicherheit Deutschlands
garantiert werden kaufen wir gemeinsam
in ausreichender Menge ein wie wird der
Verteilschlüssel sein nach Bedarf wie
viel mehr kostet dem Steuerzahler die
gemeinsame Beschaffung im Vergleich zur
nationalen Beschaffung dazu gab es heute
vom Bundeskanzler keine Antworten
gemeinsam mit den europäischen Staaten
die Energieversorgung sicherzustellen
kann ein Weg sein wenn Deutschland nicht
mehr investieren muss und mit allen
europäischen part im guten Kontakt und
nicht teilweise im Krieg stehen würde
der Kontinent Europa verfügt über
ausreichend Energiereserven um sich zu
versorgen deshalb wäre zusätzliches
teures und schmutziges fracking-gas
einzukaufen überhaupt nicht notwendig
dafür braucht es aber eine Infrastruktur
die durch die Gemeinschaft auch
gesichert wird und in diesem
Zusammenhang frage ich Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler wo sie die
Untersuchungsergebnisse zur Sabotage an
Nordstemmen 1 und 2 wo die Ergebnisse
sind die habe ich schon vor einer Woche
gefragt sie haben noch in der letzten
Woche gesagt dass diese bald vorliegen
werden nun weigert sich Schweden uns
untersuchungsdetails zu nennen und da
frage ich sie entspricht das einem
vertrauensvollen Umgang innerhalb der
Europäischen Gemeinschaft gehen so
Freunde mit uns um
wir hatten und wir haben mit den
nordstream Pipelines die Möglichkeit als
Deutschland souverän und preiswert
unsere Energieversorgung sicherzustellen
und ebenso könnten darüber Teile Europas
auch bedient werden wir haben immer
dafür geworben dass ich die deutsche
Bundesregierung Option offen halten muss
Optionen um selbst handlungsfähig zu
bleiben damit der Wohlstand der
Wirtschaft der Industrie und damit der
Bevölkerung gesichert wird alles das
setzen sie mit ihren selbst entfachten
Wirtschaftskrieg der sich hauptsächlich
gegen uns gegen unsere Bevölkerung
richtet auf Spiel ihre Maßnahmen und
Hilfsprogramme kommen spät und sind
immer wieder schlechte Kompromisse die
in erster Linie den Bürger langfristig
nur Kosten verursachen denn auch die 200
Milliarden neues Sondervermögen sind
neue Schulden die am Ende der
Steuerzahler sowieso bezahlen muss das
ist das übliche Spiel linke Tasche
rechte Tasche und die sind oben drei zum
Teil verfassungswidrig wie ist der
Bundesrechnungshof bereits schon
angekündigt hat und ich habe schon oft
gesagt sie hantieren ungeschickt und
dann an den Symptomen herum anstelle
sich den Ursachen endlich zu widmen und
diese liegen aktuell in ihrer Politik
der Sanktion daran scheinen sie wirklich
mittlerweile gefallen zu entwickeln
schauen Sie mal durch die wertebrille
Frau Werbung welche ist das nächste Land
von dem sich distanzieren wollen sie
gehen ja da schon eifrig voran es ist
schon wirklich eigenartig das gerade aus
der Partei die einmal für Offenheit und
tolerant stand nun die größten
Oberlehrer kommen diese würden zur
Durchsetzung ihrer sogenannten Werte
mittlerweile auch Waffen sprechen lassen
wollen
Diplomatie jedenfalls gehört nicht zu
ihrer Stärke das beweisen sie gerade in
den Reihen der Ampelkoalition bei den
Bürgern arbeiten sich immer weniger
Respekt und Glaubwürdigkeit das sieht
man ja nicht nur in den
Umfrageergebnissen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister bescheinigt
zudem die Erfolge einer eigenen Politik
Tag für Tag wenn er von Höchstpreisen
für Energie einer kommenden Rezession
und den Niedergang der deutschen
Wirtschaft spricht und da muss man sagen
die Politik von Robert Habeck wirkt sie
sorgen nämlich dafür aktiv dass wir zu
einem Schwellenland oder zum Sorgenkind
Europas werden und Sie sollten wirklich
und das sollte ich wirklich Arabic sich
mal überlegen darüber nachdenken ob sie
ihr Amt noch zum Wohle des deutschen
Volkes ausfüllen oder sich besser wieder
in die Welt der Fabelwesen zurückziehen
sollte
zum Bundeswirtschaftsminister
zum Bundesfinanzminister Herr Lindner
sie sprachen in Dresden vor
jung-handwerks meistern und ich zitiere
wo sie noch sie erinnern sich Witze über
ihren Kollegen Lauterbach und Habeck
machten vor wenigen Wochen haben sie das
dort den jungen Handwerksmeister gesagt
ich zitiere wir müssen all das tun was
Energiepreise runterbringt und all das
unterlassen was Energiepreise steigen
lässt in einer solchen Situation muss
man alle Kapazitäten die verfügbar sind
am Netz behalten
allerdings über Ostern hinaus und er in
Dresden erzählen sie das den Leuten was
sie dort hören wollen und hier in Berlin
machen sie genau das Gegenteil mit ihrer
Politik das ist die verlogene Politik
der FDP das ist die verlogene Politik
gegen Handwerk und gegen Mittelstand und
das haben die Wähler in Niedersachsen
bereits erkannt
und da kann ich Ihnen nur sagen lieber
Herr Linda lügen haben kurze Beine und
deshalb sollten sich wirklich warme
Unterwäsche besorgen dann ist es bei
Bodenfrost
das Grundverhältnis von Angebot und
Nachfrage ebenfalls haben sie noch nicht
erkannt und es ist immer noch vorhanden
und dabei ist gerade das Angebot auf dem
Energiemarkt weiterhin stabil nur sie
verändern Werte Bundesregierung durch
ihre aggressive Sanktionspolitik den
Zugriff auf den Markt und reduzieren das
Angebot sie entscheiden nämlich
plötzlich nicht mehr bei jedem Anbieter
zu kaufen
und möchten von denen die mit
Deutschland noch Geschäfte machen
Produkte kaufen die sie gar nicht mehr
im Angebot haben das ist die Realität
und so verknappen sie selbst das
Energieangebot das beste Beispiel sind
dafür sind die Verhandlungen mit
Saudi-Arabien oder auch Kanada mit einem
Lächeln Kern sie nach Hause zurück und
müssen anschließend immer wieder
feststellen dass die sogenannten
Lieferanten von LNG Gas überhaupt kein
adäquates Angebot für uns haben und da
sehen sie es wieder was wir immer sagen
in der Politik geht es nämlich um
Interessen herr Scholz und nicht nur um
Freundschaften das ist die Realität
meine Damen und Herren auf der
Regierungsbank machen sie sich endlich
ehrlich und gestehen sich selbst ein
dass ihr Konzept der Energiewende nicht
trägt und die Energiewende ist
gescheitert und auch sie herrnhart
sollten das endlich realisieren Ihr
stellvertretender Bundesvorsitzender aus
Sachsen hat es bereits getan und sie
sind mitverantwortlich sie sind
mitverantwortlich dass diese
Energiewende gescheitert ist denn sie
haben die Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet
das sollen wir nicht vergessen
und die schädigen nachhaltig auch die
CDU was Generationen vor uns mühevoll
errichtet haben und alles nur um ihre
ideologischen Leitlinien zu erfüllen
eine gesunde Umwelt ist die
Lebensgrundlage für alle Menschen und
zukünftigen Generationen darüber sind
wir uns ja hier in diesem Haus einig wie
wir dieses Ziel Sozial- und
wirtschaftlich verträglich erreichen
wollen das ist jedoch die Frage und
deshalb brauchen wir im Bereich der
Energieversorgung Optionen jedoch sind
in Deutschland eine Unmenge an
Windrädern und unkonventionelle
Erdgasförderung ebenso wenig eine Option
wie die endlose Förderung von Braunkohle
ja auch die ist endlich das wissen wir
wir brauchen einen gesunden Energie-Mix
der bezahlbar und vor allen Dingen
grundlastfähig ist und gerade in einem
Industrieland wie Deutschland kann man
nicht regelbare grundlastfähige Energie
wie Kohle Kernenergie und Gas durch
volatile Energie wie Wind und Sonne
ersetzen
und wer der Grünen Fraktionen dazu
braucht man nicht mal einen Studien oder
Berufsabschluss das ist einfach gesunder
Menschenverstand
sie möchten mit allen unmöglichen
Mitteln das westliche Werte und
Wirtschaftssystem retten und sind dabei
die Kommandeure des eigenen Niedergangs
aber gerade wir in Europa müssen doch
interessengeleitete Politik für unsere
Bürger machen der Kontinent Europa hat
einen festen Platz in einer multipolaren
Weltordnung dafür brauchen wir Frieden
Stabilität und vor allen Dingen
wirtschaftliche Souveränität sie und
ihre einseitige US-amerikanische
Ausrichtung sind die Totengräber der
deutschen Wirtschaft und das sehen wir
jeden Tag kommen Sie bitte zum Wohle des
Volkes zur Vernunft versuchen sie
endlich ihre ideologischen Interessen
zurückzustellen im Moment verpokern sie
alles Kapital zugunsten einseitiger
transatlantischer Bündnisse bzw neuer
Abhängigkeiten Deutschland jedenfalls
nutzt ihre Politik nichts
sie spalten damit nicht nur Europa
sondern auch die Weltgemeinschaft noch
eben sicher geglaubte Wirtschaftspartner
werden sich ab und suchen sich neue
Kontakte wie zum Beispiel Saudi-Arabien
und seinem Plan den brixstaaten
beizutreten und deshalb fordere ich Sie
für die Glaubwürdigkeit gegenüber
unseren europäischen Partnern auch bei
diesen Gipfel auf erstens sorgen Sie
schnellstmöglich dafür dass die drei
stillgelegten und die drei aktiv
verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke über den
April 23 hinaus die Energieversorgung
sichern dafür braucht es jetzt auch neue
Brennelemente
und im übrigen wäre das genau die Stunde
des Parlaments wir fordern eine offene
von den Fraktionen nicht beeinflusste
Abstimmung namentlich denn hier geht es
um Verantwortung jeder Abgeordnete soll
das in seinem Wahlkreis erklären auch
diejenigen die sich der Realität
verweigern das ist Demokratie und das
fordern wir
zweitens klären Sie die
sabotageanschläge auf die
nordstream-leitungen auf sorgen Sie
dafür dass die kritischen Infrastruktur
auch geschützt wird und geschützt ist
dass durch die Pipelines auch wieder Gas
nach Deutschland und Europa geliefert
wird und drittens beenden Sie Ihre Werte
geleitete Sanktionspolitik und stoppen
Sie die Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine
helfen sie den Krieg in Europa durch
Verhandlungen zu beenden und hören Sie
auf Moral und Sittenpolizei hören sie
auf Moral und Sittenpolizei auf der
ganzen Welt zu spielen Herr Lamsdorf
agieren sie endlich souverän Symbole
unseres Landes und zum Wohle unserer
deutschen Bürger vielen Dank
Tino der Parteien Fraktionschef der AFD
der Bundestag debattiert nach der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
zur Aussprache zum Europäischen Rat
heute und morgen und der nächste der
hier das Wort ergreift ist Christian
Dörr der Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kollegen
Kollegen Europa
bleibt geprägt durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine die
Verbrechen gegen die Bevölkerung die
täglichen Menschenrechtsverletzung das
bewusste und willkürliche Töten von
Zivilisten von Menschen Familien das
geht weiter dieser Tage der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine gehört
leider zum Alltag der Menschen in der
Ukraine doch er darf niemals etwas
Alltägliches werden meine Damen und
Herren die russische
die russische Strategie hat sich ja
dieser Tage geändert das wird deutlich
30% des Stromnetzes sind zerstört und
mittlerweile über 1000 Orte ohne
Stromversorgung russland zeigt dass es
auf stumpfe Zerstörung aus ist die
Terrorisierung der Menschen in der
Ukraine ist das strategische Ziel Putins
und herru parlam
eigentlich wollte ich nicht auf diese
absurde Rede eingehen aber es ist
notwendig denn das was sie hier
betreiben ist täteropferumkehr es ist
übrigens die Empfehlung dass sich
Deutschland aus der westlichen
Staatengemeinschaft verabschiedet wie
absurd es ist nicht im nationalen
Interesse was sie hier sagen das was sie
sagen richtet sich auch gegen
Deutschland es ist absurd so etwas
hierzu überhaupt der Opalla der
Aggressor sitzt im Kreml sind ihre
Freunde im Kreml die diese Menschen
angreifen und terrorisieren
und ich sage das deshalb weil sie von
aggressiver Sanktionspolitik gesprochen
haben aggressiver Sanktionspolitik ich
habe gerade von den Terroraktionen
Putins gegen Menschen der Ukraine
gesprochen Herr Kollege rupalla liebe
Kollegen der AFD hören sie auf so etwas
zu sagen ich will hier eines aussprechen
das was sie anempfehlen ist dass dieses
große Land dass sich Deutschland aus dem
Westen verabschiedet das darf niemals
Politik in Deutschland sein gerade nach
den Erfahrungen des Zweiten Weltkrieges
liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
denn das Ziel
das Ziel Putins ist es die Ukraine zu
zerstören damit es sich nicht mehr lohnt
über einen danach zu reden und Herr
Bundeskanzler ich bin Ihnen dankbar dass
sie genau über dieses danach gesprochen
haben das müssen wir bereits heute trotz
der schrecklichen Bilder tun wir müssen
über einen europäischen marschallplan
für die Ukraine reden und ein erster
ganz wichtiger Schritt ist die
wiederaufbaukonferenz am 25.10 hier in
Berlin wir wollen die Ukraine beim
Wiederaufbau unterstützen das wollen wir
bereits heute in aller Klarheit sagen
genauso wie wir die Ukraine bei ihrem
Weg nach Europa unterstützen liebe
Kollegen Kollegen und ich will direkt
jetzt natürlich auf die Auswirkungen auf
Deutschland auf die Menschen in
Deutschland und unsere Wirtschaft zu
sprechen kommen Deutschland Europa
befinden sich aktuell in einem
energiekrisenmodus deshalb ist es so
wichtig zu betonen dass die Bekämpfung
der Inflation und der hohen
Energiepreise natürlich für uns alle
höchste Priorität hat und wir wollen
vermeiden dass es zu strukturbrüchen
kommt wir müssen uns in Europa auf
unsere großen Stärken deshalb besinnen
unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke die
Solidarität und Geschlossenheit der
Europäischen Union und auf Demokratie
und Freiheit und Herr Kollege
Entschuldigung gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung aus
der afd-fraktion
ja
ich neige normalerweise nicht dazu aber
ich finde die dürfen sich auch
öffentlich lächerlich machen
Kollege bistron sie haben das Wort ja
vielen Dank Kollege dürr dass sie auch
in so einer Ärztin ernsten Situationen
noch ihren Humor bewarnt das ist gut sie
haben ausgeführt dass der Aggressor in
Moskau sitzt das stimmt
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen
nicht Deutschland und wenn sie sagen wir
sind als ein Teil Westen sondern wir
dürfen uns davon nicht verabschieden das
ist auch richtig aber ein Teil des
Westens waren wir schon immer und es war
eine gute deutsche Außenpolitik übrigens
liberale und sozialdiberale Koalition
haben sie betrieben die auf Versöhnung
ausgerichtet war auf Diplomatie nicht
auf Eskalation und es waren liberale
Außenminister die sich für Dialog
eingesetzt haben und nichts anderes
fordern wir von der von der AFD
[Applaus]
und wir hatten hier diese Woche gerade
einer Expertenanhörung die uns bestätigt
haben dass die USA einen aggressiven
Wirtschaftskrieg betreiben die ziehen
gerade Schlüsselindustrien in die USA
ist es werden Firmen hier in Deutschland
machen wir gehen pleite andere Firmen
wandern in die USA ab also bitte öffnen
sie die Augen sehen Sie das ganz
deutlich dass ihr trotz atlantischer
Partner auf unsere Kosten Politik
betreibt und Wettbewerber vom Markt
verdrängt und Firmen zu sich nach Hause
holt und davor warnen wir sie das war
der der Schlüssel der der die
Kernaussage der Rede von unserem
Vorsitzenden also verkennen Sie das
bitte nicht
also ich will eins betonen ziehen Dank
Frau Präsident wenn ich Antworten darf
auf diese Frage das ist nicht mein
transatlantischer Partner sondern seit
vielen Jahrzehnten unser
transatlantischer Partner die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika den
Frieden nach Deutschland gebracht haben
die den Frieden nach Deutschland
gebracht haben und der tiefere Sinn wenn
ich es so sagen nach Ihrer Frage und die
tiefere These lautet ja wie folgt und
deswegen bin ich dankbar dass wir das
hier einmal ansprechen dürfen die Tiere
these dahinter lautet ja man dürfe nicht
Waffen die von dir Vorsitzender als hier
gerade erklärt sondern man müsste reden
niemand in der Ukraine niemand hier
kommt doch auf die Idee zu sagen wir
würden uns nicht bereits heute Nacht
wünschen dass Frieden in der Ukraine
herrschen und das ist genau das was ich
mit täteropfer Umkehr meine Herr Kollege
natürlich wollen wir Frieden so schnell
wie möglich dort sterben Menschen dort
sterben jeden Tag Kinder und Familien
liebe Kollegen Kollegen es ist doch
Wladimir Putin der nicht über Frieden
reden will sondern kampfdrohen nach Kiew
geschickt hat das ist doch die Wahrheit
liebe Kollegen Kolleg und das Recht der
Ukraine sich zu verteidigen ist
abzusprechen indem wir Waffenlieferung
das wäre die wahre und Menschlichkeit in
diesem Konflikt vielen Dank dass ich das
an der Stelle war noch einmal darstellen
durfte ich will jetzt Frau präsidente
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen auf die
Europäische Union und das was wir
energiepolitisch richtigerweise tun
können und machen sollten zu sprechen
kommen und Herr Kollege Merz sie haben
einen wie ich finde richtigen Punkt
angesprochen den ja die Bundesregierung
die regierungstragenden Fraktionen
bereits im Abwehrschirm für die deutsche
Wirtschaft für unser Land für die
privaten Haushalte mit verankert haben
nämlich ein belastungsmoratorium es war
auch ein wichtiger Wunsch meiner Partei
Herr Kollege Merz ich teile Ihre
Einschätzung dass das auf europäischer
Ebene auch der Fall sein sollte ich will
es mal etwas entschuldigen Sie die
Wortwahl über spitz sagen es gibt
Wahlkämpfe der CDU die nicht erfolgreich
waren oder nach einem CDU-Mitglieder auf
ihre Autos den Aufkleber gemacht meckert
nicht ich habe CDU gewählt ich will
Ihnen antworten bei der Europawahl
meckert nicht ich habe FDP gewählt ich
würde mir wünschen dass die
cdu-kommissionspräsidentin das was sie
hier richtigerweise Tag und ich hoffe
sie haben ihre Nummer das was sie hier
richtigerweise vorschlagen auch zur
Politik der Europäischen Kommission
macht sie haben uns voll an ihrer Seite
das ist aber keine Frage die hier zu
entscheiden ist sondern die
cdu-kommissionspräsident sollte diesen
Weg gehen wenn wir das zusammen machen
können Herr Merz wäre ich sehr dankbar
und glücklich das wollte ich gesagt
haben zu diesem guten Vorschlag
und es ist aber richtig dass wir
gleichwohl auf europäischer Ebene
gemeinsame und konkrete Schritte gehen
beispielsweise der Vorschlag Verein
gemeinsam Gaseinkauf insbesondere für
die Füllung der gaspeicher was ja wieder
notwendig sein wird im kommenden Winter
für die Jahre 2023 und 24 es ist ein
richtiger Gedanke hier ein Mechanismus
zu finden die preisdynamiken im
europäischen Gasmarkt zu verringern denn
insbesondere mit Blick auf LNG ist die
Dämpfung der Preise im Großhandel durch
neue Referenzpunkte extrem wichtig
solche technischen Dinge müssen auf
europäischer Ebene geklärt und gemacht
werden daher ist es richtig dass wir
sowohl auf europäischer als auch hier in
Deutschland auf nationaler Ebene jetzt
Schritte einleiten auch zur Ausweitung
des Angebots und deswegen habe ich es
für richtig gehalten dass der
Bundeskanzler erklärt hat dass das
Bundeskabinett dass die Bundesregierung
den Deutschen Bundestag eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
über diesen Winter hinaus vorschlagen
wird allein das Kernkraftwerk im
niedersächsischen Emsland wird in dieser
Zeit 6,8 Millionen Menschen mit Strom
versorgen gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
auch an die Energiepreise heran
die diese Strom- und Gaspreise kann sich
kein privater Haushalt kann sich kein
mittelständisches Unternehmen leisten
und deswegen werden wir im Rahmen des
abwehrschirms eine gaspreisbremse und
eine strompreisbremse für Deutschland
installieren meine Damen und Herren die
200 Milliarden Euro die dort an
kreditermächtigung bereit werden
bereitgestellt werden sollen ist ja
nicht das Ziel einfach nur Geld
auszugeben meine Damen und Herren
sondern die klare Aussage zu tätigen mit
diesen hohen Preisen wird niemand allein
gelassen in Deutschland als
Solidargemeinschaft werden wir das
gemeinsam stemmen sein ganz ganz
wichtiges Signal dieser Tage lieber
Kollegen Kollegen und wir haben weiteres
getan die entlastungspakete sind von
meiner Kollegin Hasselmann vorhin schon
angesprochen worden auch die Volumen der
entlastungspakete suchen ihresgleichen
wir werden beispielsweise im Rahmen des
inflationsausgleichs bereits für das
kommende Jahr auch steuerlich die
Menschen und um die Arme greifen denn
die hart arbeitende Mitte in Deutschland
die diesen Steuerstaat trägt die hat
genau verdient liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und wir werden mit der gaspreisbremse
über Einmalzahlung im Dezember und dann
zu echten Reduzierung beim Gaspreis im
kommenden Jahr für die Unternehmen aber
auch für die industriellen Verbraucher
und insbesondere für die privaten
Haushalte die richtigen Schritte machen
aber ich will zum Schluss frau
Präsidentin sagen ich habe das vorne in
Bezug auf die Ukraine bezogen aber das
gilt auch für Deutschland und Europa wir
sollten mehr als nur raus aus der Krise
wir wollen eben auch an morgen denken
meine Damen und Herren und ich will an
der Stelle sagen dass deutsche
energiegeschäftsmodell die niedrigen
Gaspreise und gleichzeitig hohe
Unternehmenssteuern das ist dieser Tag
in Gefahr weil eine Säule weggebrochen
ist und deswegen müssen wir uns auch
energiepolitisch international
diversifizieren beispielsweise immer
energiepartnerschaften mit Afrika auf
der europäischen Ebene wird gerade das
Thema synthetische Kraftstoffe
verhandelt wie wäre es denn wenn wir
gemeinsam mit Afrika es hinbekommen dass
wir Energie von dort bekommen in Zukunft
aber gleichzeitig dadurch eben auch
zusätzliche Entwicklungsarbeit dort
betreiben können liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und
ein Punkt heute bereits an morgen zu
denken ist
dass wir die nächste Krise die unseren
Wohlstand in Deutschland bedroht bereits
in den Blick nehmen und das ist der
heftige Arbeitskräftemangel bereits der
kostet uns bereits Wohlstand und
Wirtschaftswachstum deswegen wird diese
Koalition eine fachkräfteeinwanderung
bereits in dieser Woche mit einem ersten
Schritt und kommende Schritte werden in
diesen Monaten folgen auf den Weg
bringen meine Damen und Herren gerade
die Einwanderung in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt den Fehler der alten
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung endlich
zur korrigieren das wird Wohlstand in
Deutschland in Zukunft sichern meine
Damen und Herren und macht unser Land
aus krisenfläster auch das will ich
unterstrichen haben
und
deswegen sage ich zum Schluss ich bin
für alle Vorschläge die dieser Tage
gemacht werden weil es gibt nicht den
einen perfekten Vorschlag sehr sehr
dankbar und Herr Merz sie haben mir in
ihrer Rede gerade immer wieder angemahnt
dass man mehr machen müsste aber das
Geheimnis was sie stattdessen
vorschlagen würden sind sie aus meiner
Sicht schuldig geblieben und das ist
nicht leicht keine Frage aber ich will
einen Vorschlag von ihnen aufgreifen der
vergleichsweise der vergleichsweise
konkret war sie haben gesagt anstatt 300
Euro für jeden sie haben ja gerade im
Finanzausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages die 300 Euro für die
Rentnerinnen und rentnerbewusst
abgelehnt ich halte das für ein Fehler
aber das muss noch mal gesagt werden
aber ich will ihn ich will ihn eins
sagen der Vorschlag zu sagen stattdessen
1000 Euro für das untere Drittel klingt
zunächst gut aber was heißt das denn
konkret was heißt das für den
Arbeitnehmer und die Arbeitnehmerin die
genau einen Euro mehr verdient als das
untere Drittel die gingen komplett leer
aus und da bin ich beim Bundes Tesla wir
lassen in Deutschland niemanden alleine
ich bin dankbar für Vorschläge der
Opposition das ist auch ihre Aufgabe
aber Sie müssen so konkret sein dass man
sie auch in deutsche Politik umsetzen
kann herzlichen Dank
Christian dürr der
fDP-Fraktionschef war das und in der
Aussprache zum europäischen oder hat
heute und morgen hat jetzt Amira [ __ ]
mit Ali Fraktionschefin der
Linksfraktion das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Bundeskanzler sie und ihre
Regierungsmitglieder nennen sich ja
selbst gern die
fortschrittskoalition leider ist das
einzige was in unserem Land ernsthaft
voranschreitet die Spaltung der
Gesellschaft Millionen Menschen wissen
nicht mehr wie sie ihr ganz normales
Leben bezahlen wollen unsere Wirtschaft
droht eine schwere Rezession in ihrer
Regierung aber herrscht das Chaos und
wenn es darum geht die Bevölkerung
wirksam zu entlasten dann wird endlos
gezögert und gezaudert und was dann
rauskommt ist meistens morgens Chaos und
Murks bei den späteren
entlastungspäckchen Chaos am Umgang mit
Christian Lindners heiliger Kuh der
Schuldenbremse und auch die
atomkraftdebatte hat wieder gezeigt dass
es ihnen vor allem darum geht den
jeweiligen Befindlichkeiten ihrer
ministergerecht zu werden und eben nicht
um die Belange der Bevölkerung aber das
geht so nicht
man stelle sich einmal vor Sie hätten
all die Stunden die sich sinnlos
gestritten haben dafür genutzt die
Menschen vor der Preisexplosion wirksam
zu schützen indem sie zum Beispiel den
versprochenen strompreisdeckel
eingeführt hätten oder einen
vernünftigen gaspreisdeckel und zwar
jetzt und ich am Ende der Heizperiode im
März was ist das denn
und auch heute haben sie sich wieder
gelobt für ihre lächerlichen
entlastungspäckchen und ich möchte dazu
eines sagen ich meine sie als
Norddeutscher sollten doch wissen es
reicht nicht den Deich auf zwei Meter
aufzuschütten bei zehn Meter Hochwasser
da braucht es mehr und die Katastrophe
zu verhindern das ist die Wahrheit wir
brauchen sofort ein energiepreisdeckel
Verbrauch ohne Verbraucher genauso wie
die kleinen mittelständischen
Unternehmen und zwar auch bezahlbaren
Niveau außerdem müssen alle Haushalte
mit kleinem mittleren Einkommen wirksam
entlastet werden wir wollen 1500 Euro
wintergeld pro Haushalt plus 600 Euro
für jedes weitere Haushaltsmitglied das
würde wirklich etwas bringen und wenn
sie sagen das dafür kein Geld da sein
dann ist das einfach Quatsch besteuern
sie endlich die perversen übergewinne
der Energiekonzerne die liegen jetzt
schon bei über 100 Milliarden Euro
außerdem führen sie endlich eine
gerechte Vermögensteuer ein ich meine
wenn Sie trotz dieser existenziellen
Krise immer noch nicht bereit sind die
Superreichen gerecht zu besteuern dann
regieren sie einfach an den Belangen der
Mehrheit vorbei so ist das leider und
außerdem muss selbstverständlich die
Schuldenbremse auch im nächsten Jahr
ausgesetzt werden alles andere ist
unverantwortlich Vernunft wo die
Ideologie das muss auch in der
Finanzpolitik endlich gelten
der Präsident
der Chemieindustrie der warnt davor
Deutschland könne vom Industrieland zum
Industriemuseum werden in der
Stahlbranche droht aktuell tausenden
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern der
Arbeitsplatzverlust denn wenn sich die
Lage nicht bald deutlich verbessert dann
wird die Produktion nach und nach in
Länder mit geringeren Energiekosten
verlagert werden das darf nicht
passieren Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch ihre außenpolitische Bilanz die ist
leider ernüchternd ja seit fast acht
Monaten tobt bereits Putins
schrecklicher Krieg in der Ukraine und
es muss doch eigentlich endlich auch bei
Ihnen die Erkenntnis gereift sein dass
dieser Krieg nicht weiter eskalieren
darf nein er muss möglichst schnell
beendet werden und das geht nur über
Verhandlungen ja es braucht jetzt
Diplomatie statt Waffenlieferungen und
es geht eben nicht das möchte ich mal in
aller deut vielleicht sagen das
denjenigen die das aussprechen was
vernünftig ist das denen unterstellt
wird dass sie Verständnis hätten für
Putin das ist einfach Blödsinn und es
macht das Geschäft genau von denen die
diese Argumente instrumentalisieren für
ihre Hetze das ist die Wahrheit
es ist instrumentell sie sind doch sonst
immer für Aufrüstung unsere
militärisierung nein unsere Haltung ist
der konsequent nur Diplomatie und
Vernunft sind der richtige Weg und das
gleiche das gleiche gilt übrigens auch
für berechtigte Kritik an den
allgemeinen Wirtschaftssanktionen fakt
ist diese Sanktionen die Schaden
Deutschland der EU und den Ländern des
globalen Südens enorm Russlands
Kriegsmaschinerie rollt aber
unbeeindruckt weiter die russische
Wirtschaft ist weiterhin stabil herr
Scholz sie haben selbst versprochen es
würde keine Sanktionen geben die uns
mehr Schaden als Russland handeln sie
endlich danach
und bevor sie uns jetzt weiter oder
wiederkommen mit ihrer angeblichen
wertebasierten Außenpolitik sie
unterhalten beste Beziehung zu
Diktaturen wie zum Beispiel nach Saudi
Arabien dahin liefern sie jetzt sogar
Kampfjets Kampfjets mit denen die sauge
Luftmasse Waffe systematisch Zivilisten
im Jemen bombardiert in diesem
schrecklichen Krieg sind bereits 400.000
Zivilisten ermordet worden und das
Sterben geht weiter und ihre
Außenministerin an einer der bärbock die
sagt dazu allen Ernstes man müsste ja
nun mal die Bündnisverpflichtung
erfüllen und ohne diese Lieferung der
Kampfjet und Saudi-Arabien kümmerte
Deutschland in sozialen Bereich ja noch
mehr sparen Kampfjets für die
Kindergrundsicherung so stand es
treffend im Spiegel ich meine wie
zynisch ist das denn und wie zynisch ist
das eigentlich den Kindern im Jemen
gegenüber nein Menschenrechte die müssen
immer und überall gelten und eben nicht
nur da und dann wenn es in
geopolitischen in den Kram passt danke
mit dem Ende der Rede von Amira mit
Mohammed Ali Patong verlässt der
Bundeskanzler jetzt den Sitzungssaal
denn er muss ja dann auch gleich los
nach Brüssel und hat aber hier die erste
Rede Runde abgewartet bis eben zur
Fraktionschefin der Linksfraktion jetzt
Achim Post für die SPD
frau Präsidentin bisher hat diese
lebendige Debatte viel
Dissens gezeigt das ist gut so das ist
legitim das gehört dazu sie hat an einer
Stelle gezeigt dass die Einschätzung
über die Bedeutung dieses Gipfels
ähnlich hoch ist das ist nicht irgendein
Gipfel
das ist nicht irgendein Krisengipfel das
wäre ein Untertreibung
die Regierungschefs die Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben vor sich
krisengebirge mit sich überlappenden
Krisen
und da kann ich nur sagen das steht in
keinem Drehbuch da steht in keinem
Koalitionsvertrag dafür gibt es keine
Blaupause
dafür braucht man andere Dinge
Vernunft
Pragmatismus
Lösungsorientierung Handlungsfähigkeit
und einen starken Bundeskanzler und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin
froh dass wir einen starken
Bundeskanzler haben der nach diesen
Maßstäben handelt und auch auf diesem
Gipfel handeln wird
und ich finde dass die Bundesregierung
liefert
das kann ich überhaupt nicht als
lächerlich einschätzen oder sind 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr lächerlich nein sie sind es
nicht oder sind drei entlastungspakete
in Höhe von 95 Milliarden Euro
lächerlich nein sie sind es nicht oder
sind die angekündigten 200 Milliarden
Euro zur Entlastung bei den
explodierenden Energiepreisen lächerlich
nein liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie
sind es nicht
und diese Bundesregierung
liefert auch politisch sie hat ihren
Beitrag dazu geleistet ihren großen
Beitrag dazu geleistet dass Europa eben
nicht gespalten ist wie sich er Putin
das vorgestellt hat sondern geeint ist
bei den Sanktionen die schwierig sind
aber richtig sind und notwendig sind
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und bei
der Politik die sie jetzt betreibt und
die sie auf dem Gipfel weiter betreiben
wird Europa steht zusammen Deutschland
agiert im europäischen Kontext und im
Kontext der NATO und das ist richtig so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
Herr Merz wenn sie mit ihrer durchaus
berechtigten heftigten heftigen zum Teil
fundamentalen Kritik an der
EU-Kommission an ihrer Parteikollegin
aus der CDU Deutschlands Frau von der
Leyen oder auch an der Christdemokratin
aus Malta Roberta Mezzola der
Präsidentin des Europäischen Parlaments
Kritik üben das ist völlig in Ordnung
wenn sie das machen dann habe ich eine
Frage
bisher habe ich gedacht bisher habe ich
gedacht bisher habe ich gedacht es gibt
in Europa es gibt bei diesen großen
Parteien bei den großen Volksparteien in
Deutschland Konsens das ist richtig ist
die Demokratie in Europa zu stärken das
glaube ich weiter gibt es auch Konsens
die Demokratien in Europa zu stärken
daran habe ich mittlerweile meine
Zweifel reicht es nicht aus dass wir
einen Orban haben und seine kompanionen
reicht es nicht aus dass wir eine
illiberale Demokratie haben und andere
in der Europäischen Union muss auch
jetzt noch Schweden und Italien und im
nächsten Jahr vielleicht Spanien dazu
kommen und warum können die dazu kommen
weil Manfred Weber der Chef der EVP der
Türöffner ist für Bündnisse von
Christdemokraten konservativen mit
Populisten Rechtspopulisten und
Postfaschisten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und und ich bin dankbar ich bin wirklich
dankbar dass der Vorsitzende der CSU
Markus Söder sehr deutlich gesagt hat
dass die CSU und auch eher persönlich
eine Brandmauer wollen zwischen diesen
ganz Rechtsaußen und demokratischen
Parteien von ihnen höre ich Herr März
gar nichts ein dröhnendes Schweigen das
ist alles das ist nicht genug
und wir brauchen jetzt zusätzlich
krisenreaktionsfähigkeiten die über den
Tag hinausgehen wir müssen
Zukunftsinvestitionen tätigen in
batteriezellfertigung in erneuerbare
Energie in Impfstoffe und vieles andere
mehr dazu ist die Europäische Union in
der Lage und sie wird auf diesem Gipfel
weiter dazu in der Lage sein und wir
brauchen beides Vertiefung und
Erweiterung der Europäischen Union ja es
ist richtig dass wir mehr als
Entscheidungen brauchen in vielen
Bereichen aber es ist genauso richtig
die nächsten Schritte zu gehen bei der
Erweiterung der EU bei der Erweiterung
und den westlichen balkern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn auch das gehört zur Politik dazu
auch zur Politik in Europa man muss
zudem stehen was man versprochen hat die
Europäische Union Deutschland auch hat
2003 in Thessaloniki versprochen wenn
die Kriterien eingehalten werden können
die Mitglieder des westlichen Wahlkampfs
nach und nach Mitglied werden es ist
fast 20 Jahre her um das einzulösen wir
sollten damit anfangen auf diesem liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zusammengefasst es steht viel auf dem
Spiel
dieser Bundeskanzler diese
Bundesregierung dieser
Bundesfinanzminister dieser
Wirtschaftsminister und diese
Außenministerin werden dieser
Verantwortung gerecht denn wie gesagt
das wichtigste ist jetzt pragmatisches
Handeln Handlungsfähigkeit für
Deutschland und Europa schönen Dank
Achim Post war das für die SPD und sie
haben es gesehen der Bundeskanzler ist
doch noch mal zurückgekommen denn 15 Uhr
beginnt der Gipfel in Brüssel der hat er
dann doch noch ein bisschen Zeit hat
noch mal seinem Freund Achim Post
zugehört und ich glaube beim nächsten
reden würde auch noch mal zuhören
Alexander Dobrindt der landesgruppenchef
der CDU CSU und erste Stellvertreter von
Friedrich Merz in der Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
Herr Bundeskanzler wir warten seit
Wochen dass sie sich im Deutschen
Bundestag erklären wir haben sie
mehrfach schriftlich aufgefordert hier
im Deutschen Bundestag zur Lage der
Nation zu sprechen und eine
Regierungserklärung abzugeben dass sie
das heute getan haben das ist zu
begrüßen aber dass der Anlass dazu eben
nicht die Nöte die Sorgen die
Ängste der Bürger waren sondern
ausschließlich der Sitzungsplan in
Brüssel das müssen sie sich vorhalten
lassen der Bundeskanzler
mit welcher Mission fahren Sie jetzt
eigentlich nach Brüssel in welcher Rolle
treten sie in Brüssel jetzt eigentlich
auf ich erwarte dabei überhaupt nicht
dass sie den Anspruch ihres
Parteivorsitzenden erfüllen der von der
Führungsmacht Deutschland gesprochen hat
aber ich erwarte dass sie den Anspruch
haben in Europa Orientierung zu geben
darum geht es in diesen Zeiten und
Deutschland hätte jetzt eine Blaupause
liefern können für eine wirksame
strompreisbremse für eine wirksame
gaspreisbremse in Europa sie tun es
gerade nicht Herr Bundeskanzler
die gaskommission hatte die
Vorschläge vorgelegt des fehlen
weiterhin die Entscheidungen dazu dieser
Bundesregierung sie lassen die Menschen
in Unsicherheit das gibt keine
Orientierung in Europa sie hätten ein
klares Signal heute geben können an
Europa für solide und stabile Finanzen
in Wahrheit haben sie ein fatales Signal
von Schattenhaushalten nach Brüssel
gegeben sie haben heute hier kein
einziges Wort über die Finanzfragen die
in Brüssel anstehen verloren kein
einziges Wort Herr Bundeskanzler vor
wenigen Tagen haben sie allerdings beim
Parteikongress der europäischen
Sozialisten gerne darüber gesprochen
dass Europa Schulden Vergemeinschaftung
braucht mit welchem Signal gehen Sie
jetzt eigentlich nach Brüssel der
Bundeskanzler
und sie hätten auch ein deutliches
Signal geben können dass Deutschland
die Ukraine mit zusätzlichen modernen
schweren Waffen unterstützt sie hätten
eine gemeinsame Lieferung von westlichen
Kampfpanzern innerhalb der Europäischen
Gemeinschaft ermöglichen können seit
Monaten scheitert die Bereitschaft aus
europäischen Ländern diese Lieferungen
durchzuführen an der Zögerlichkeit
Deutschlands hier fehlt es an
Orientierung aus Deutschland in Europa
und liebe Kolleginnen
sehr geehrte Frau Hasselmann sie haben
hier davon gesprochen
in Richtung der
cdu/csu-fraktion wo sind sie in ihrer
Verantwortung das waren ihre Worte
liebe Frau Hasselmann weil sie sicher so
sehr für stärkere Waffenlieferungen
einsetzen ich will ihnen sagen wo unsere
Verantwortung ist 100 Milliarden
sonderschulden im Grundgesetz
ausschließlich für die Bundeswehr zur
Verfügung die sind deswegen entstanden
weil wir all ihre Versuche der
Zweckentfremdung dieser Gelder
verhindert haben da ist unsere
staatspolitische Verantwortung
Herr Dobrindt gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Bemerkung von Frau
Hassmann
bitte sie haben das Wort
Herr Dobrindt weil sie das Ansprechen
und so tun als sei das eine große
staatspolitische Verantwortung gewesen
ich bin froh und dankbar dass sie
zugestimmt haben in der Tat aber ehrlich
gesagt war das auch meine Erwartung an
sie denn
wer vier
bundesverteidigungsminister:innen
gestellt hat in den letzten 16 Jahren
und die Bundeswehr so
runtergewirtschaftet hat wie sie das
gemacht haben
wir waren deshalb in der Situation zu
einem Sondervermögen greifen zu müssen
wie hätten Sie es denn sonst gemacht
warum haben sie diese Verantwortung in
den letzten 16 Jahren für die Bundeswehr
nicht wahrgenommen und ich kann mir
nicht verkneifen zu sagen warum waren
sie eigentlich so engstirnig die
kritische Infrastruktur die
Sicherheitsarchitektur die notwendigen
Investitionen in cybersicherheit und das
was notwendig ist zu verweigern wir
stehen da heute in einer großen
kritischen Situation uns dem Thema zu
widmen das sehen wir durch die
Sabotageakte hier in Europa
indirekt haben sie gerade zugegeben dass
sie offensichtlich ein großes Interesse
daran hatten ein wesentlichen Teil
dieser 100 Milliarden unter ihren grünen
Ministerinnen und Ministern aufzuteilen
und nicht in die Bundeswehr zu
investieren
genau das haben wir verhindert dass sie
diese Mittel anders verwenden das ist
für sie ein Rendezvous mit der Realität
ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen
dass ihnen das schwer fällt regieren ist
doch schwerer als moralisieren das ist
das was sie jetzt offensichtlich zur
Kenntnis nehmen
und wäre die Lage ehrlicherweise nicht
ganz so ernst dann könnte man sich
mancher vollmundiger Sätze die ich in
den letzten Tagen von Ihnen und anderen
gehört habe auch auf ihrem Parteitag
durchaus auch mit Humor begleiten aber
die Lage ist nun mal so ernst und
deswegen lassen sie sich auch daran
erinnern wenn sie sagen wir Grüne tragen
diesen Staat diese Gesellschaft und
diese Demokratie dann lassen sie sich
sagen ihre offene Kompromiss Unfähigkeit
ihre ideologische Verweigerungshaltung
ihr Ignorieren der Ängste und Nöte der
Menschen das trägt diese Gesellschaft
nicht sondern es ignoriert diese
Gesellschaft das ist die Wahrheit an
dieser Stelle
der Bundeskanzler die Menschen sind
schwer verunsichert viele haben schlicht
Angst diese Woche hat die R+V Studie zu
den Ängsten in Deutschland neue Zahlen
veröffentlicht Geld sorgen dominieren
die Ängste der deutschen 67 Prozent
haben Angst sich ihr Leben nicht mehr
leisten zu können sie haben Herr
Bundeskanzler einen doppelbums
angekündigt steht geblieben ist davon
nur doppelte Fragezeichen Ausgestaltung
der gaspreisbremse unklar Ausgestaltung
der strompreisbremse unklar Sicherheit
der Netzstabilität unklar diese Politik
schafft kein Vertrauen sie schafft neue
Ängste meine Damen und Herren
die Kommission hat die Vorschläge
gemacht sie haben bisher nicht darauf
reagiert sie sagen nicht wie sie
Haushalte wie sie Wirtschaft wie sie
Mittelstand entlasten wollen aber sie
fordern von uns ein dass sie Zustimmung
bekommen für 200 Milliarden neue
Schulden diese hier morgen zur
Abstimmung stellen sehr geehrter Herr
Bundeskanzler lassen Sie sich dies an
dieser Stelle auch sagen diesen Blanco
Wumms werden Sie von uns schlichtweg
nicht bekommen
[Applaus]
und was sie diese Woche abgeliefert
haben in ihrer Koalition das hat die
Ängste übrigens nicht kleiner werden
lassen ihr Machtwort zu notwendig das
offensichtlich auch war ist ein Zeichen
der Ohnmacht diese Koalition und wenn
Sie schon Herr Bundeskanzler ihr
schärfstes Schwert die
Richtlinienkompetenz des Kanzlers wenn
sie es schon nutzen warum denn dann
nicht konsequent sondern nur
halbherzig kein einziges Problem dass
sie offensichtlich anders als ihr
Wirtschaftsminister für Januar Februar
und März identifiziert haben ist im
April des nächsten Jahres gelöst
deswegen ist ihre Entscheidung falsch an
dieser Stelle die Kernkraft nicht
weiterlaufen zu lassen
der Bundeskanzler sie haben hier vorhin
an diesem Rednerpult gesagt die
Energiepreise sind eine große
Bewährungsprobe ja vor allem für die
mittleren und kleinen für die normalen
Einkommen für den Mittelstand sie haben
hier vorhin an diesem Rednerpult gesagt
die Energiepreise müssen runter warum
verweigern sie den Menschen dann die
preisentlastung durch das Weiterlaufen
der Kernkraftwerke des Ifo-Institut hat
deutlich gemacht weiterlaufen der
Kernkraftwerke ist ein wesentlicher
Beitrag zur Reduzierung der
Energiepreise in Deutschland kommen sie
ihren eigenen Einspruch nachher
Bundeskanzler
ich habe übrigens vermisst Herr
Bundeskanzler dass sie
hier ihr ständiges versprechen
wiederholt haben dass wir inzwischen von
ihnen gewohnt sind you never walk alone
dieses ständige versprechen was die FDP
jetzt auch schon für sie wiederholt hat
noch mal eine ganze besonders
interessante Wendung in dieser Woche
bekommen wenn man sich das Verhalten
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition innerhalb
ihrer Bundesregierung angeschaut hat
wissen Sie Herr Bundeskanzler wie der
Blick der Öffentlichkeit der Bevölkerung
auf diese Ampel auf diese Regierung
inzwischen ist hier sitzt der
Bundeskanzler you never walk alone und
neben ihm sitzt üblicherweise der
Vizekanzler Deadman Walking das ist der
Blick der Bevölkerung auf diese
Bundesregierung
wenn es an Machtwort braucht Herr
Bundeskanzler dann überlegen Sie sich
bitte ob Sie nicht dieses Machtwort
wirklich sinnvoll nutzen wollen es wäre
notwendig in dieser Lage jetzt die
Bestellung der Brennstäbe vorzunehmen
den weiterlauf der Kernkraft zu
ermöglichen Versorgungssicherheit zu
schaffen und Preise zu senken das wäre
ein Auftrag den Sie mitnehmen können
nach Europa nach Brüssel wenn sie
Machtworte sprechen dann sorgen Sie auch
für Ergebnisse die den Nöten der
Menschen helfen dankeschön
der musste eben sogar der Bundeskanzler
Schmunzeln
Alexander Dobrind wieder voll in seinem
Element mit einer ziemlich harten
Abrechnung mit der Politik der
Bundesregierung und insbesondere mit den
im Bündnisgrünen nächste Rednerin hier
in der Aussprache zum Europäischen Rat
heute und morgen nach der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
Chantal Kopf für die bündnisgrüne
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen seit einigen Tagen liefert
Frankreich Gas nach Deutschland dass wir
nach unserer selbstverschuldeten
Abhängigkeit von Russland benötigen und
Deutschland wiederum hilft Frankreich
bei der Stromversorgung das ist gelebte
europäische Solidarität
nun kommt es aber darauf am gesamt
europäisch die Energiepolitik und die
gaseinkäufe deutlich besser zu
koordinieren damit Putin die EU-Staaten
nicht noch einfacher gegeneinander
ausspielen kann und übrigens auch nicht
Länder in anderen Welt teilen gegen
Europa
wenn wir von überlappenden Krisen
sprechen dann müssen wir noch viel
ernsthafter über das Klima sprechen die
EU macht sich mit dem Green Deal und mit
Fit for fifty five auf den Weg zur
Klimaneutralität und auch wenn wir noch
nie ambitioniertere Pläne hatten um
unsere Lebensgrundlagen zu sichern sind
wir noch weit vom Ziel entfernt und
jetzt hat Putins Wirtschaftskrieg den
Kontinent in eine Energiekrise gestürzt
die existenzielle sorgen auslöst Hilfe
Entlastung Solidarität sind das Gebot
der Stunde aber
wenn Rufe laut werden jetzt mal langsam
zu machen mit Sorgfaltspflichten mit
Klimaschutz mit dem Green Deal dann ist
das genau die falsche Antwort der Green
Deal gilt wir können nicht warten bis
alle anderen Krisen irgendwie irgendwann
verschwunden sind die Klimakrise wartet
darauf nicht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und das hat uns denn in diese Situation
in dieser Abhängigkeit von Autokratien
gebracht unser blindes Vertrauen in
fossile Energie deswegen müssen wir uns
endlich befreien von fossilen
Brennstoffen deswegen brauchen wir einen
Energieeffizienzgesetz deswegen brauchen
wir den vorgezogenen Kohleausstieg und
deswegen setzt die Ampel alle Hebel im
Bewegung um den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
zu beschleunigen
für die Energiewende benötigen wir aber
auch die europäische Ebene den Ausbau
und den Schutz einer gemeinsamen
Energieinfrastruktur in der EU und in
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft gemeinsame Projekte bei
Solar bei Wind und bei grünem
Wasserstoff
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn wir
uns an die Fluten im Aartal erinnern an
den zurückliegenden Hitze Sommer und vor
allem wenn wir an die 1700 Hochwasser
Toten im Pakistan denken dann wird klar
wir brauchen nicht weniger Tempo beim
Klimaschutz sondern wesentlich mehr
Paris gilt ich bin unsere
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock
dankbar dass sie eine group of friends
für eine ambitionierte EU-Klimapolitik
auf den Weg gebracht hat die EU muss die
Pariser Klimaziele beim Wort nehmen und
sie muss sich noch stärker ihrer
Verantwortung gegenüber den Ländern
bewusst werden die am stärksten von der
Klimakrise betroffen sind obwohl sie am
wenigsten dazu beigetragen haben
wir leben in Zeiten in denen Menschen
aufgrund von Dürren und Fluten ihre
Heimat verlieren und in denen
Ungerechtigkeit zwischen globalen Norden
und globalen Süden auch zunehmend zum
geostrategischen Risiko wird liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
was wir jetzt brauchen das ist
Kooperation auf Augenhöhe das sind faire
Energie
transformations- und
handelspartnerschaften die sowohl der EU
aber eben auch unseren Partnern den Weg
in eine lebenswerte Zukunft ebnen und
das ist auch unsere Antwort auf Putins
Imperialismus und auf die Einflussnahme
eines autoritären Chinas in Asien Afrika
und auf dem gesamten Globus und apropos
China lassen Sie uns bitte nicht unsere
Fehler wiederholen wir dürfen uns nicht
erpressbar machen es ist nicht klug
wichtige Infrastruktur in die Hände
Chinas zu geben lassen sie uns endlich
eine vorausschauende Politik machen eine
vorausschauende Politik dafür stehen
Bündnis 90 die Grünen vielen Dank
Chantal Kopf war das für die Bündnis
Grünen und der nächste Redner hier in
der eigentlich europapolitischen Debatte
ist ein wahrer Europäer lange dort
gewesen Mensch viel zu Präsident gewesen
und jetzt der zweite Saturn im Bundestag
Alexanderplatz
in der Ukraine nimmt auf unserem
Kontinent unterschiedlich
Erscheinungsformen an wir wissen dass
Russland gegen uns ein energiekrieg
führt in der großen Analyse der vier
deutschen Übertragungsnetzbetreiber
heißt es die Situation im Deutschen
stromnetzwert im kommenden Winter
äußerst angespannt all die hat gestern
angekündigt aus Energiekosten Gründen
seine Öffnungszeiten zu verkürzen
Ingenieure von stromnetzbetreibern sind
derzeit dabei zu prüfen Kunden in
Süddeutschland zeitweise vom Netz zu
nehmen weil es dort nicht gelingt die
Versorgung mit Strom aus den Windparks
im Norden sicherzustellen und das will
ich hier deutlich sagen meine Damen und
Herren bei aller Offenheit für Debatten
die der Bundeskanzler hier eben
angesprochen hat einen Beitrag braucht
und das sind Tipps der CSU für die
Energieversorgung in unserem Land gerade
der Freistaat Bayern ist der Problembär
unter den
Bundeswehr darum geht die
Energieversorgung zu sichern die gute
Nachricht meine Damen und Herren in
diesem Zusammenhang ist dass die drei
Kernkraftwerke die noch laufen jetzt am
Netz bleiben das hat der Bundeskanzler
in dieser Woche verkündet und diese
Nachricht meine Damen und Herren die
freut auch unsere europäischen Partner
denn wir sind in der Europäischen Union
nicht nur aus politischen Gründen zu
unserem Glück vereint wir sind auch
durch Pipelines und Kabel und
interconnectoren miteinander verbunden
und vernetzt wir haben profitiert von
den flüssiggast Terminals und dem
pipeline-kapazitäten in Holland und
Belgien und Skandinavien die haben dafür
gesorgt dass unsere Gasspeicher gefüllt
werden konnten wir helfen den Franzosen
wenn bei denen die Kernkraftwerke
teilweise ausfallen mit Stromlieferungen
aus Deutschland jetzt kriegen wir Gas
aus Frankreich meine Damen und Herren
wenn bei uns ein Netz Engpass auftritt
wenn bei uns Strommangel auftritt dann
hat das unmittelbare Folgen für unsere
Nachbarn in der Europäischen Union
deswegen muss der Weiterbetrieb der
bayerischen Kernkraftwerke auch als eine
symbolische Geste gesehen werden er
verhindert nämlich die Erzählung von
einem Deutschland das einerseits die
Hilfe seiner Partner in Anspruch nimmt
aber andererseits nicht dazu bereit ist
seine eigenen Befindlichkeiten bei der
eigenen Energieversorgung
zurückzustellen Deutschland muss seine
energieerzeugungskapazitäten jetzt
ausschöpfen im Interesse aller unserer
europäischen Nachbarn und der ganzen
Europäischen Union bleiben wir also
meine Damen und Herren zu unserem Glück
vereint ich hoffe das ist das Signal das
von diesem Europäischen Rat ausgeht
herzlichen Dank
ja diese Hoffnung teilen viele bleibt
abzuwarten ob es da wirklich zu
Ergebnissen kommt heute und morgen bei
einer gemeinsamen Energiepolitik der
Europäer Matthias Miersch jetzt für die
SPD liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Kollege Dobrindt
ich habe eben mitgeschrieben und ich
hoffe dass ich sie richtig wiedergebe
und es aber inhaltlich einen
Missverständnis gewesen ist sie haben
gesagt auf die Frage der Kollegin
Hasselmann
wir sollten hier Ängste und Nöte der
Menschen nicht ignorieren Herr Kollege
Dobrindt diese Vorwürfe finde ich
sollten wir gerade in dieser Zeit nicht
unter Demokraten machen wir nehmen hier
alle die Ängste und Nöte von weiten
Teilen der Bevölkerung ernst aber unsere
Antworten unsere Vorschläge sind
vielleicht unterschiedlich das sollte
unser Konsens sein hier in diesem Haus
und wenn sie dem Bundeskanzler Herr
Dobrindt und Herr Merz vorwerfen man
kann es nicht und man handelt nicht dann
finde ich müssen Sie sich einfach auch
immer wieder gefallen lassen dass wir
uns mit ihren Vorschlägen denn so wie
sie überhaupt da sind dann
auseinandersetzen der Kollege dürr hat
einen ihrer Vorschläge ja schon mal
gemacht drei will ich Ihnen hier sagen
und ich kann ihn nur sagen ich bin
heilfroh dass in diesen Zeiten nicht sie
regieren sondern die der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz und kein anderer der ruhig
hier diese Bundesregierung führt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn was sie als erstes ganz groß
verkündet haben nach wenigen Wochen des
Kriegsausbruchs war dass sie
vorgeschlagen haben und da kann man sie
nie aus der Verantwortung lassen dass
die dass die Bundesregierung ein
einseitiges Gas embargo gegenüber
Russland verkünden sollte das wäre fatal
für alle in Deutschland gewesen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und jetzt kommen Sie mit dem nächsten
und sagen es gibt eine große Lösung die
alles
das sind die Laufzeitverlängerung und da
muss man Ihnen noch sagen dass twittert
sogar noch der zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Jens Spahn dass diese Technologie
putinfrei und verlässlich sein wissen
Sie eigentlich welche Abhängigkeiten
zwischen russischen Brennstäben und
osteuropäischen Atomkraftwerken bestehen
wer hier von Putin freisprechst der hat
das ganze Thema nicht verstanden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wer von Verlässlichkeit redet und
sich anguckt was gerade in Frankreich
passiert wo die Hälfte der
Atomkraftwerke nicht am Netz ist der
sagt hier den Menschen etwas Falsches
ich hätte mir gewünscht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das so wieder
Bundeskanzler von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz gebraucht macht
dass Frau Merkel manches Mal im
Auseinandersetzung mit ihnen bei den
erneuerbaren Energien gemacht hätte dann
wären wir weitaus weiter gewesen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ganz fatal Herr dobend jetzt müssen
sie es noch mal auch ganz kurz angucken
jetzt haben sie hier geredet eben und
haben gesagt man müsste in irgendeiner
Form Bremsen einführen
energiepreisbremsen und sie haben
scheinbar den Bundeskanzler nicht
zugehört denn er hat sich heute
ausdrücklich zu den
kommissionsergebnissen bekannt und hat
gesagt diese Bundesregierung arbeitet
gerade an der Umsetzung und das ist ein
Riesenschritt dass wir hier jetzt
Sicherheit geben Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
und Unternehmen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber was machen sie was machen sie in
dieser Phase sie werden morgen den 200
Milliarden die notwendig sind um diese
Sicherheit zu geben nicht zustimmen weil
sie keinen Blankoscheck angeblich geben
wollen woher sollen denn bitte die
Gelder kommen die im Dezember die
Haushalte stützen sollen das macht
keinen Sinn sie irrlich dann in dieser
Krise und Sie können es schlichtweg
nicht stellen sie sich nicht hier hin
und sagen sie können und Sie können es
nicht sondern sie müssen wirklich
belastbare Vorschläge hier vorlegen alle
drei Punkte wären dieser strös gewesen
in dieser in dieser Krise gut dass sie
nicht regieren vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
es ist immer noch die Aussprache zum
Europäischen Rat hier im Deutschen
Bundestag nach der Regierungserklärung
des Bundeskanzlers heute morgen hat
jetzt als nächster Redner guter
Kriechbaum von der cdu/csu der
europapolitische Sprecher das Wort frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
Herr Bundeskanzler wir haben heute
Morgen sehr entschlossene Worte von ihm
gehört zum Thema Ukraine und dem
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine das begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
wir hätten uns aber diese Rede und
diesen Inhalt schon vor einem halben
Jahr gewünscht diese Entschlossenheit
haben sie immer vermissen lassen und
Fakt ist eben auch dass durch die
Zögerlichkeit durch das Zaudern
insbesondere beim Thema der
Waffenlieferungen viele Menschenleben
hätten gerettet werden können wenn auch
wir in Deutschland früher gehandelt
hätten das ist allerdings nicht der Fall
sie haben auch über Europa geredet die
Frage die sich mir stellt welches Europa
meinen sie eigentlich ist es ein Europa
der Gemeinsamkeiten oder ist das ein
Europa der Alleingänge sie haben nichts
gesagt zu Frankreich sie haben nichts
gesagt zu China sie haben nichts gesagt
zu den USA gestern wurden die
deutsch-französischen
Regierungskonsultationen abgesagt mit
der Begründung dass vier Minister ihres
Kabinetts
paralleltermine hätten keine Zeit hätten
ist Ihnen in diesem Augenblick
eigentlich bewusst dass wo wir doch alle
wissen dass diese Begründung ohnehin
vorgeschoben ist welche unglaubliche
Affront das Gegenüber Frankreich ist zu
sagen die haben besseres zu tun als an
den deutsch-französischen
Regierungskonsultationen teilzunehmen
das ist ein Schaden dem Sie hier dem
Verhältnis von Deutschland und
Frankreich zufügen wir hätten genügend
Themen zu besprechen mit unseren
französischen Freunden wie geht es
weiter bei FKS sie hatten auf ihre
Prager redebezug genommen da hatten sie
auch vom Raketen Abwehrschild gesprochen
mit Frankreich 0,0 kommuniziert
überhaupt kam das deutsch-französische
Verhältnis in der Prager Rede überhaupt
gar nicht vor dass sich Frankreich dann
darin nicht wiederfindet darf wohl kaum
Erstaunen wir hätten uns gewünscht dass
sie heute Abend heute morgen noch etwas
gesagt hätten beispielsweise zum Thema
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft welche Perspektive wird den
Beitrittskandidaten geboten das ist ein
Vorschlag der ebenfalls von macron kam
kein Wort dazu China gehen wir weiter
China sie werden China bereisen Anfang
November auch wiederum ein Alleingang
nicht mit den europäischen Freunden und
Partnern kommuniziert es wäre die
Gelegenheit gewesen ähnlich wie es
macron im übrigen auch einmal gemacht
hatte dass er Bundeskanzlerin Merkel
Jean-Claude Juncker und eben auch den
chinesischen Präsidenten an einen Tisch
geholt hatte dann über die Dinge zu
sprechen die uns in Europa gemeinsam
bewegen wenn wir wissen dass zwei
Drittel aller Halbleiter weltweit aus
Taiwan kommen wenn wir wissen dass eine
hundertprozentige ab Möglichkeit
gegenüber China bei der Frage der
Antibiotika besteht dann wäre es schon
einmal sinnvoll diese Dinge europäisch
anzugehen und nicht in einem nationalen
Alleingang wir haben
wir haben einen weiteren eyeline allein
kann das ist dieser hummi Wumms mit 200
Milliarden Euro
0,0 mit den europäischen Partnern
kommuniziert abermals Sendepause es wäre
gut gewesen auch hier im Vorfeld wie das
im übrigen auch früher der Fall war mit
Frankreich und mit den anderen
europäischen Freunden zu sprechen
richtig ist dass wir hier die deutsche
Wirtschaft unterstützen falsch ist es
das alleine zu machen und ohne jede
Kommunikation mit unseren Freunden
ebenfalls ein Alleingang und ohne die
Kommunikation Thema Energie es ist gut
dass jetzt die Laufzeit der Kraftwerke
der Kernkraftwerke verlängert wird aber
wir dürfen uns doch hier nicht in die
eigene Tasche lügen es ist ein
streckbetrieb bis April es wäre besser
gewesen dem Vorschlag auch der FDP hier
zu folgen und die Laufzeit der AKWs
generell zu verlängern das wäre jetzt
erforderlich gewesen zumal Europa wir
auch an der Stelle kritisch beäugt
werden es heißt nämlich ihr deutschen
wenn ihr jetzt die Angebotsseite
verknappt dann verteuert sich eben nicht
nur die Energie für euch sondern eben
auch für uns den Strom ist ein gut was
international gehandelt wird und Angebot
und Nachfrage Regeln nun einmal den
Preis aber
auf Finanzminister Lindner ich muss
Ihnen schon auch sagen
ist persönlich war jedenfalls erstaunt
dass als es um die 200 Milliarden ging
sie als Finanzminister da ein anderes
Preisschild nicht dahinter gehängt war
sie hätten nämlich locker sagen können
wie ich mache es als Finanzminister zur
Bedingung dass die Laufzeiten der AKWs
entsprechend verlängert werden und dann
erteile ich auch als Finanzminister
meine Zustimmung das war ein schwerer
strategischer Fehler den Sie innerhalb
der Verhandlungen hier gemacht haben und
das müssen sie sich eben auch angreifen
lassen
wir haben kein Fortgang beim Thema ceta
Wie geht es hier voran auch das wäre
heute morgen eine perfekte Gelegenheit
gewesen hier einmal etwas zu sagen
Klarheit zu schaffen zum x-mal hier im
Deutschen Bundestag verschoben das ist
ein affrong Gegenüber Kanada stattdessen
möchte ihr Wirtschaftsminister hier
die Verhandlungen mit Chile wieder auf
die Handelsbeziehung mit hier das
Handelsabkommen mit Chile wieder
aufmachen vielleicht sollte man mal auch
daran denken dass die Handelspolitik
eine Kompetenz ist die zu 100 Prozent
bei der Europäischen Union liegt und
nicht beim Wirtschaftsminister der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland deswegen war
diese Regierungserklärung eine Rede der
verpassten Chancen und generell sollte
vielleicht das afrikanische Sprichwort
beherzigt werden wenn du schnell gehen
willst dann gehe alleine aber wenn du
weit gehen willst dann geh gemeinsam und
wir brauchen mehr Gemeinsamkeit in
diesen kritischen Tagen
und der Kriechbaum ist europapolitischer
Sprecher der CDU CSU endet hier mit
einem afrikanischen Sprichwort seiner
Rede Rednerin ist Ariane
sie ist im Ausschuss für Angelegenheiten
der Europäischen Union für die SPD redet
sie sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Werte
sind die komplexeste Krise seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg
zeitenwände zeitenwände mit vielen
Dimensionen deswegen möchte ich jetzt
den Blick einmal etwas weiter wenden in
die Langfristperspektive eine enorme
Solidarität und Entschlossenheit ist
eine EU sichtbar geworden darin zeigt
sich eine erneuertes Europa eine
belastbare Gemeinschaft jenseits der
Konfliktfelder erstagter Nationalismen
eingeschränkter Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
Pressefreiheit
Krisen sind die Stunde der Exekutive
Achim Post wies zu Recht auf die
Notwendigkeit der Vertiefung und
Erweiterung der EU hin eine erweiterte
Europäische Union wird langfristig
gelingen wenn ein Europa der Regierungen
als ein Europa der Menschen und er
füttert werden kann so fordern ist die
Ergebnisse der Zukunftskonferenz und so
fordert es der bürgerblick auf die EU
einer der Gründerväter der europäischen
Einigung der französische Beamte
jean-monnaie ließ uns den Satz zurück
Europa wird in Krisen geschmiedet und
ist am Ende die Summe der Lösungen die
für diese Krisen gewählt wird diese
Krise hat die Macht uns entweder zu
entweihen oder sie wird uns befähigen
jene Probleme zu lösen die aus
mangelnder Zusammenarbeit und
Uneinigkeit entstanden sind hier kann
insofern eine wirkliche europäische
Chance erwachsen
in der Debatte in Deutschland ist die
europäische gender- und
Gleichstellungspolitik ein
unterschätzter Aspekt
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit und
gleichberechtigte Teilhabe aller
Menschen sind kein Selbstzweck sondern
Voraussetzungen für nachhaltigen Frieden
Sicherheit und Wohlstand der Europäische
Rat wird mit sich heute und morgen den
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
stets lag die Stärke der Gemeinschaft in
ihrer Fähigkeit tragfähige Brücken nach
außen zu schlagen wie aktuell mit der
europäischen politischen Gemeinschaft
eine wachsende EU wird jedoch neben
einer gemeinsamen Wirtschafts- und
Sozial- und Sicherheitspolitik nur als
ein Europa der Mehrheitsentscheidung
gestärkt da innerer Demokratie und mehr
gemeinsamer Steuer- und Fiskalpolitik
stark bleiben können
das Europa der gleichen
Lebensverhältnisse und einer
europäischen Identität gelingt wenn der
Tiefe der Zusammenarbeit von Regierungen
über die Parlamente in die
Bürgerschaften reicht dafür sind
allerdings lose Zusammenschlüsse zu
wenig
die EU ist wichtige Schritte für ein
modernes gerechtes Europa der
BürgerInnen gegangen da ist die
lohntransparenzrichtlinie die
arbeitnehmer:innen Einblick in die
Entlohnung gleichgestellter Kollegen
ermöglicht so lässt sich Lohngefälle
zwischen den Geschlechtern verringern
aber auch zwischen Menschen
unterschiedlicher Herkunft und
Berufsabschlüsse
EU-weit verdienen Frauen 14% weniger als
ihre männlichen Kollegen
europaweit sind aber auch vor allem
Frauen Verliererinnen der Krise sie sind
verstärkt auf der Flucht allein mit
Kindern und alten Angehörigen sie sind
stärker von der Energie-
Gewalt und sexualisierte Gewalt an
Frauen und Kindern nimmt in Krisen nicht
nur zu sondern sie werden nach gerade
als Kriegswaffe eingesetzt
neben Energiesicherheit und Frieden wird
gelingender Klimaschutz wird immer mehr
wird gelingender Klimaschutz immer mehr
zur Grundlage für gleiche
Lebensverhältnisse nicht nur zwischen
den Geschlechtern sondern auch zwischen
den Ländern und Regionen der
klimasozialfonds ist ein gelungener
Ansatz der solidarischen Antwort auf die
sozialen Herausforderungen des
klimagerechten Umbaus der Wirtschaft
auch der europäische Mindestlohn ist mit
erstmals einheitlichen lohnstandards
eine zentrale Errungenschaft des
sozialen Europas atypische Beschäftigung
niedrigste Löhne prekäre Arbeit wie in
plattformökonomie und das Lohngefälle
zwischen Geschlechtern sind Themen
die wir national aber und vor allem auf
der EU-Ebene bekämpfen können und müssen
sozial und Steuerdumping darf kein
Wettbewerbsvorteil sein nirgendwo
deswegen sind diese Vorstöße wirkliche
Pionierarbeit im sozialen Europa
europäische Erlebnis und
Erwerbsbiografie unterstützt durch
umfassende jugendbildungsprogramme
werden in der Zeit eine europäische
Identität prägen die künftigen
erasmus+-generationen werden aus einer
teilhabegerechten europasicht den
Phantomschmerz untergegangener reiche
und verlorener Großmächte ebenso wenig
spüren wie sie nationengrenzen fühlen
das Recht jeder Europäer in
das Recht jeder Europäer in auf
Sicherheit Gleichstellung und
Chancengerechtigkeit an jedem Ort an dem
sie ihr Leben gestalten möchten muss
daher der Anspruch auf die
Lebenswirklichkeit der EU für morgen
sein sie fordert Integrität Solidarität
Augenhöhe von allen Staaten nicht
weniger als das bedeutet am Ende eine
gelungene Zeitenwende für Europa vielen
Dank
Anton Hofreiter hat das Wort für Bündnis
90 die Grünen
Anton Hofreiter von den Bündnisgrünen
ist Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union so heißt das korrekt
und hat jetzt das Wort liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die großen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit die
Klimakrise wie die jetzige Energiekrise
oder den verbrecherischen Angriffskrieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine werden wir
nur bewältigen wenn wir verstärkt
europäisch zusammenarbeiten Deutschland
ist ein großes Deutschland ist ein
mächtiges Land ein Vergleich zu diesen
Herausforderungen ist es auch ein
kleines Land und wir müssen die Ukraine
noch mehr stärker unterstützen und wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass die
Ukraine noch mal mehr Waffen zur
Verteidigung bekommt und wenn ich mir
hier anhöre was von dieser Seite und
dieser Seite erzählt wird nämlich dass
man die Waffenlieferungen einstellen
soll und doch einfach mal verhandeln
soll dann ist es naiv und verantwortlich
und einfach schlichtweg unter
Hilfeleistung
denn sie fordern sozusagen auf das Opfer
zu Verhandlungen aber haben Sie
eigentlich gemerkt dass Russland die
Ukraine angegriffen hat und das Russland
nicht bereit ist zu verhandeln und da
hilft es nichts die Opfer aufzufordern
zu verhandeln sondern hilft es die Opfer
zu unterstützen dass sie sich wehren
können nur dann haben wir eine Chance zu
echten Verhandlungen zu kommen nur dann
haben wir eine Chance zufrieden zu
kommen
[Applaus]
möchten Sie eine Zwischenfrage zulassen
es scheint mir so
Jan Karte der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der Linksfraktion frau
Präsidentin vielen Dank Kollege
Hofreiter als ich will auf die Polemik
jetzt gar nicht weiter eingehen aber ich
hätte schon noch mal eine konkrete
Nachfrage wenn sie sagen dass also die
Forderung nach Verhandlungen also per se
unmoralisch oder sonst irgendwas ist
also das ist schon relativ absurder
Ansatz vor allem wenn er vom linken
Flügel der Grünen hier vorgetragen wird
ist aber eine andere Frage was mich
wirklich noch mal interessieren würde
wenn wir sowohl mal zurückgehen nehmen
wir mal den großen Bundeskanzler Willy
Brandt der hat ja damals also
beispielsweise mit Leonie Breschnew
verhandelt der jetzt ja nun kein
basisdemokrat gewesen ist fangen sie
deswegen diese Art von Politik
eigentlich falsch und was sagen sie
eigentlich zu den Verhandlungen die
beispielsweise
uterisch geführt hat auch mit dem
putin-regime als es um die Auspuff von
Weizen ging halten sie das jetzt auch
per se für unmoralisch das würde mich
interessieren wie da ihre Stellung zu
ist
vielen Dank für diese äußerst
ungeschickte Frage wenn ich sie haben
bewusst versucht die Wahrheit zu
verdrehen nämlich was ich ihnen vorwerfe
ist dass sie die Ukraine nicht weiter
unterstützen wollen und nicht weiter mit
Waffen unterstützen wollen nämlich das
haben Sie gesagt Sie wollen keine
weiteren Waffen an die Ukraine liefern
das ist nichts anderes als wir
unterlassene Hilfeleistung dann gibt es
nämlich gar keine Verhandlungen mehr
weiß nämlich dann gar keine Ukraine mehr
gibt es gäbe keine Ukraine mehr wenn wir
Ihre unverantwortliche Politik die sich
interessanterweise mit denen denken
umsetzen würden und das ist das Problem
das ist das Problem des unanständige an
ihren Forderungen
und jetzt und jetzt sozusagen zur Union
es ist ja allgemein bekannt
Teilung bin und die Bundesregierung
dränge noch mehr zu tun und ich höre es
auch immer wieder aus der Union dass die
Bundesregierung mehr tun sollte aber
wenn wir mitten in der Debatte sind ob
die Bundesregierung noch mehr tun sollte
und ich bin froh was wir bereits
geliefert haben dann meldet sich die
Union und Herr Merz persönlich zu Wort
und wirft den Ukrainern sozialtourismus
vor das ist ein russisches Propaganda
narrativ und damit konterkarieren sie
alle Bemühungen die Ukraine noch stärker
zu unterstützen und dann sind sie nicht
bei in der Lage sich ernsthaft zu
entschuldigen sondern nur halbka das
macht die ganzen Bemühungen die dringend
notwendig sind einfach unglaubwürdig
jede Kritik ist russische Propaganda ja
also und es ist so ab und man muss halt
ehrlicherweise sagen ja wir tun vieles
auf europäischer Ebene aber wir müssen
einfach auch noch stärker werden wir
haben zu lange gezögert das müssen wir
uns ehrlich anrechnen dass wir auf
europäischer Ebene für ein gemeinsamen
erdg Einkauf kämpfen da waren wir zu
langsam das ist gut dass wir das jetzt
tun aber wir müssen doch schneller
werden und wir müssen auch klarer werden
auf der einen Seite dürfen wir nicht
drauf reinfallen wenn uns gesagt wird
die 200 Milliarden bei uns sind
uneuropäisch wenn andere Länder das
gleiche machen aber es fällt halt leicht
wenn wir so kommunizieren wie wir es zum
Teil getan haben deshalb ich glaube in
allen Feldern tut es uns allen gut wenn
wir als Bundesregierung als
Regierungsfraktionen im Idealfall als
Gesamtes wenigstens als alle Demokraten
im Parlament noch stärker darauf achten
was sind die Interessen was sind die
Bedürfnisse unserer Nachbarn und dafür
sagen dass wir europäisch gemeinsam
zusammenhalten nicht dann sind wir stark
vielen Dank
das Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wenn ich so die
Kritik der Opposition an der
Regierungserklärung des Kanzlers heute
höre da muss ich feststellen
substanziell war das jetzt nicht von
ihnen nicht Herr Merz etc sondern da war
eigentlich gar keine Kritik das heißt so
schlecht kann das heute morgen gar nicht
gewesen sein sondern der Bundeskanzler
hat sehr deutlich gesagt was die Haltung
der Bundesregierung was die Haltung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist und mit
welcher Haltung er in diesen
Europäischen Rat geht und dass er das
zentrale Ziel hat dort zu einer Einigung
zu kommen mit unseren europäischen
Freundinnen und Freunden und das ist gut
für unser Land und das ist gut für
Europa
eines ist klar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Energiekrise diese Energiekrise
diese Energie Preiskrise kann nur
europäisch gelöst werden das ist
deutlich geworden heute morgen es geht
um einen gemeinsamen Einkauf es geht um
Preisgrenzen für den Gasmarkt auch das
muss europäisch gelöst werden es geht um
die Solidarität der Mitgliedstaaten und
es geht zentral auch darum gemeinsam
Energie zu sparen darum geht es in
diesen Fragen
und deshalb sind erste Schritte gemacht
worden es ist heute morgen auch schon
erwähnt worden es wird ein gemeinsam
Gaseinkauf geben auf europäischer Ebene
und es gibt Gaslieferungen aus
Frankreich und es gibt unsere
europäische Verantwortung auch zu
unseren europäischen Partnern auch sie
mit Gasen unterstützen beispielsweise
Tschechien die Gas brauchen die aber
auch Strom liefern also das ist alles zu
begrüßen und ich bin der
tiefenüberzeugung dass das auf dem
Europäischen Rat gelingen wird denn
eines ist klar Europa war immer dann
stark wenn es in der Krise sich zusammen
nehmen musste wenn es in der Krise
verstanden hat alle gemeinsam schaffen
wir das nur als Einheit und ich glaube
das ist deutlich dass man vorher bevor
man in den Rat geht auch
unterschiedliche Positionen hat das ist
durchaus richtig und das muss man auch
immer zugrunde liegen und diese
europäischen Lösungen die wir in den
nächsten zwei Tagen erwarten und auch
erhoffen und davon auch überzeugt sind
die sind der Grundstein für G7
Vereinbarungen die in der
g7-präsidentschaft der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und auch mit unserem
Bundeskanzler dann ein auf eine breitere
basisgesetz werden das ist der Punkt wo
wir sagen Europa gemeinsam und dann G7
dann wird das auch funktionieren was mir
dabei
was wir dabei aber nicht vergessen
dürfen ist und ich finde das ist heute
noch ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen in
den Debatten hier ist die Frage wie wir
mit dem globalen Süden umgehen wir
dürfen das nicht vergessen es geht um
Ernährungssicherheit es geht um
Energiesicherheit auch für die
Ärmsten und armenländer in dieser Welt
europa muss sich für diesen
Süden in engagieren sonst sind sie in
den dispoten sonst sind sie den dispoten
dieser Welt ausgeliefert dann geht es
darum dass China oder Russland deren
Politik bestimmen und das kann nicht im
Interesse Deutschlands nicht im
Interesse Europa sein und nicht im
Interesse der Demokratien in dieser Welt
das muss man glaube ich auch noch mal
herausstellen und dann will ich das auch
an der Stelle sagen ich bin da ganz ganz
zuversichtlich und auch froh dass wir
einen Kanzler an der Spitze haben der
ein europäischer Kanzler ist wir sind in
einer Krise
und zum ersten Mal bin ich sehr beruhigt
dass ein Kanzler zu einem europäischen
Rad fährt in einer Krise der nicht die
Absicht hat das auszusitzen wie wir das
16 Jahre unter Angela Merkel hier erlebt
haben das ist ein starker Kanzler und
das gehört sich auch so
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland und der
Kanzler wird sich für europäische
Lösungen einsetzen und da geht es um
wichtige Punkte die wir erarbeiten
müssen eines ist zum Beispiel auch die
Resilienz in der Energieversorgung und
den Lieferketten können wir eine
europäisch erreichen darum geht es auch
auf diesen Gipfel wir brauchen keine
nationalen alleinergänge sondern wir
brauchen
Solidarität international das heißt
europäisch und auch auf der G7 Ebene und
ich will ein Ende meiner Rede ein
Gründervater
der Europäischen Union zitieren der
vielleicht noch mal deutlich macht worum
worauf es ankommt worum es uns geht
Spark
hat Mal zitiert oder hat mal gesagt und
ich finde der Satz ist immer noch
richtig in Europa gibt es zwei Typen von
Staaten kleine Staaten und Staaten die
noch nicht verstanden haben dass sie
klein sind und das bedeutet für uns
gemeinsam Solidarität auf europäischer
Ebene und dafür kämpfen wir mit dieser
Bundesregierung in dieser Koalition und
mit diesem Bundeskanzler vielen Dank
Markus Töns war das für die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion der vorletzte
Redner in der Aussprache zum
Europäischen Rat ist Robert farle
Fraktionslose Abgeordneter war mal in
der AFD
ja
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrter
Herr Bundeskanzler Scholz
meiner Meinung nach befindet sich unser
Land in größter Gefahr
und ich glaube dass sie diese Gefahr in
ihrer ganzen Dimension
noch nicht realisiert haben
weil sie viel zu sehr einem Diktator in
der Ukraine Vertrauen der als
präsidentendarsteller des Olli garchen
kolomäuskie an die Macht gekommen ist
und im Auftrag der USA in Russland einen
Regimewechsel herbeiführen soll
dieser salenski hat vor wenigen Tagen
aufgerufen einen präventiven Atomschlag
gegen Russland durchzuführen
und schließt per Dekret sämtliche
Verhandlungen mit Putin über einen
Waffenstillstand aus
es ist eben nicht gut in der
Verhandlungen ablehnt sondern es ist der
Lenski der keinerlei Verhandlungen
bereit ist und diese Sabotage durchs
zielensky für eine friedliche Lösung zu
finden die muss durchbrochen werden und
dazu fordere ich Sie als Bundeskanzler
auf alles in diesem Sinn zu unternehmen
und aus der kriegsrätorik dieses Landes
auszusteigen die überall in unseren
Massenmedien derzeit praktiziert wird
mit Rückendeckung von beiden versucht
ganz Westdeutschland in einen Krieg mit
Russland hineinzuführen und peilt einzig
und allein eine militärische Lösung des
Konflikts an das ist Wortlaut zalensky
es gibt nur eine militärische Lösung
eines solche Militär
konventionellen
Krieg Tour macht überhaupt nicht geben
es sei denn man arbeitet final im Rahmen
einer
Eskalationsspirale Schritt für Schritt
auf den gesamten Weltuntergang hin
manche nennen das Armageddon oder sonst
wie aber ich kann Ihnen nur sagen aus
der Spirale muss man aus rauskommen in
dieser Situation ist von Ihnen Herr
Scholz Führungsstärke gefragt denn von
ihnen hängt ab dass endlich das
Wichtigste in Angriff genommen wird
nämlich endlich und sofort die
Herbeiführung eines Waffenstillstandes
einzuleiten und selensky zurückzupfeifen
der nicht über unser aller Schicksal
entscheiden kann und mit seinen
alleinggängen gestoppt werden muss
abgelaufen
[Musik]
ich hatte drei Minuten
gut wenn die rum sind das wichtigste
habe ich hier zum aus
Druck gefunden mein letzter Satz in
[Musik]
diesem sie haben die Möglichkeit
einzuwirken nutzen Sie Möglichkeit für
eine friedliche Lösung die man
Verhandlungen zustande
bringt
[Musik]
ja und das muss man auch klar sagen
nachdem ich vorhin es ja anders
interpretiert habe der Bundeskanzler ist
immer noch da er sitzt hier durch bis
zum letzten Redner der wird gleich
kommen nämlich Axel Schäfer Axel Schäfer
ist auch Sozialdemokrat und den wird er
sich jetzt noch anhören 15 Uhr beginnt
der Gipfel in Brüssel und der
Bundeskanzler hat die gesamte Debatte
hier quasi im Hohen Haus verbracht das
muss normal hervorgehoben werden bis zum
letzten renat Axel Schäfer jetzt mit dem
schönen roten Schaden frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen manchmal gibt
es besondere Zufälle was die redeabfolge
anbelangt
ich habe mich mit meinem Vorredner vor
fast 50 Jahren in Bochum darüber
gestritten
inwieweit wir die Intervention der
Sowjetunion und anderer Warschauer
pakt-staaten zur Niederschlagung des
Prager Frühlings verurteilen und dagegen
stehen einer der härtesten
Repräsentanten der DKP von MSP Spartacus
war Robert fahler der Verteidiger der
Verteidiger der Niederschlagung des
prager-frühlings Anfang der 70er Jahre
bei Bochumer Debatten ist heute
derjenige der versucht den ukrainischen
Präsidenten zu diffamieren und
niederzumachen das war eine Rede der
Schande die wir heute gehört haben
und es ist vielleicht auch ein
besonderes Stück oder Drama in der
deutschen Geschichte dass man von einem
Stalinisten zu einem
Rechtsextremisten mutieren kann ich bin
froh dass es so wenige davon in
Deutschland noch gibt und es ist gut so
dass wir die Diskussion so geführt haben
heute wie wir sie miteinander auf dieser
Seite des Hauses geführt haben
aber liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen lasst
uns
Angesicht der historischen Dimension ein
bisschen stärker auch Dinge einordnen
das was wir heute zu bewerkstelligen
haben ist tatsächlich die größte
Herausforderung seit 1945 und deshalb
müssen wir genau solche Maßstäbe anlegen
und selbst die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung war nur zum Teil
vergleichbar aber die Erfahrung von
damals waren und damals regierte FDP und
cdu/csu die SPD hatte die Mehrheit im
Bundesrat die Erfahrung damals war keine
der Parteien hatte eine Blaupause keine
hatte ein Konzept für die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung und trotzdem ist es
gemeinsam gelungen dieses zu einer
Erfolgsgeschichte zu machen wo wir ja
gemeinsam und zurechtgreif stolz sein
können
und ja es war möglich weil wir hier auf
Debatten geführt haben es war es war
damals auch möglich weil auch die
Opposition SPD insgesamt zugestimmt hat
und ich bin ganz sicher die Opposition
cdu/csu wird auch den Vorschlägen auch
was jetzt 200 Milliarden anbelangt
zustimmen ansonsten würden sie weder
ihrer deutschen noch ihre europäischen
Verantwortung bewusst
das sind wir beim liefern wir haben ja
wir haben ja das das große und das auch
historisch das große Glück bei einer
Zeitenwende
1969 Entspannungspolitik wurde eine
Bundeskanzler der schon als
Außenminister damit begonnen hat und als
es darum ging das Europäische
Währungssystem zu entwickeln bis hin zur
Direktwahl des Europäischen Parlaments
hatten wir einen Bundeskanzler der
vorher schon Finanzminister war und ich
finde es ist gut dass wir jetzt wieder
ein Bundeskanzler haben der schon als
Finanzminister in Europa gezeigt hat
Stichwort wie der Aufbau von Stichwort
globale Mindestbesteuerung dass er in
der Lage ist zu europäischen Lösungen zu
kommen die auch als praktisch umgesetzt
werden und das ist auch gut so
und liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen von der
Union weil wir bei Europa sind es wird
darauf ankommen dass wir weiterhin
kritisch was mehr sozial oder
konservativ oder liberale ökologisch und
so weiter ist kritisch diskutieren aber
eins dürfen wir nicht wir dürfen nicht
zulassen dass über die Regeln die wir
gemeinsam beschlossen haben dass die
infrage gestellt werden und die Regeln
die wir gemeinsam beschlossen haben
werden in Frage gestellt eben nicht nur
durch Regierungen in Ungarn eine frühere
christdemokratische Partei die
ausgetreten ist oder in Polen sondern in
Zukunft auch in Schweden und Italien wo
Christdemokraten gestützt mit
Postfaschisten da hängt noch der
Mussolini beim Senatspräsidenten in der
Wohnung oder den antidemokratischen
Schweden Demokraten und das haben sie
genau auch 2023 in Spanien so vor die
Union in Europa die auch gerade die EVP
wird sich entscheiden müssen ob sie
tatsächlich diese Wertegemeinschaft die
uns hier verbindet tatsächlich
verteidigt oder ob sie aus Partei
taktischen Gründen mit rechtsradikalen
und Rechtsextremisten die mit der AFD in
der Fraktion des Europäischen Parlaments
sind paktiert oder nicht genau darum
wird es gehen und wo die SPD steht wo
diese Koalition steht mit Olaf Scholz
mit dem Finanzminister Lindner mit
Harbeck und mit bärbock das ist völlig
klar und deshalb werden wir das auch
genauso hinbekommen vielen Dank
Axel Schäfer 70 Jahre alt 1994 bis 99
Mitglied im Europäischen Parlament seit
2002 hier im Deutschen Bundestag und der
Bundeskanzler hat wirklich bis zum
Schluss ausgehart mit einem gewissen
Lächeln auf den Lippen verlässt er jetzt
hier den Plenarsaal sehr schön
eingefangen wir sind allerdings nur noch
von hinten er hatte ein wirkliches
Lächeln auf den Lippen ich glaube über
die Rede seines Parteifreundes Axel
Schäfer und um 15 Uhr wie gesagt beginnt
der Europäische Rat in Brüssel und da
Berlin ja durchaus nicht so weit weg ist
von Brüssel da wird es der Bundeskanzler
auch noch rechtzeitig schaffen aber
bemerkenswert ist es schon das will ich
an der Stelle noch mal sagen an so einem
Tag hier die gesamte Debatte sitzen zu
bleiben das hat auch nicht jeder
Vorgänger oder Vorgängerin von ihm so
getan so jetzt gibt es eine Änderung
ursprünglich ein anderer Punkt geplant
der wurde aber im Ausschuss festgehalten
seistum Top 14 wird jetzt aufgerufen
Notfallfonds für das Wissenschaftssystem
den Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu und
Thomas der zombeck für die Union hat
jetzt das Wort diese Krise ganz sicher
sagen ohne Forschung und ohne
Wissenschaft ohne Technologie werden wir
uns aus der mangelage nicht befreien
können wir brauchen also die
Wissenschaft um uns zu retten aber heute
müssen wir darüber reden die
Wissenschaft zu retten wir können hier
im Deutschen Bundestag locker 20 Prozent
Energie sparen indem wir die Heizung
niedriger stellen indem wir das Licht
ausmachen aber wenn man zum Beispiel
eine bio-datenbank oder eine Genbank
betreibt wie das Unsere
Forschungsorganisation tun beim
Leibniz-Institut da werden Dinge
konserviert bei -196 grad wenn man
Tierhäuser betreibt wie das
Max-Planck-Institut mit 50.000 Mäusen
wenn man einen Supercomputer wie das
Forschungszentrum Jülich sowie Standorte
auch in Garching und Stuttgart das
machen alleine der Supercomputer
natürlich braucht 130 Gigawattstunden
pro Jahr wenn man einen
Teilchenbeschleuniger wie das Design
Hamburg hat 210 Gigawattstunden dann
wird glaube ich deutlich dass in der
Wissenschaft und Forschung nicht einfach
eben 20 Prozent gespart werden können
denn bei diesen ganzen Geräten über die
wir reden und über viele andere
Einrichtungen ist es eben so die kann
man nicht ein bisschen Herunterfahren
sondern hier reden wir über
Milliardeninvestitionen des Staates die
man am Ende einfach nur abschalten kann
und deshalb gibt es laute Hilferufe aus
der Wissenschaftsgemeinschaft Frau
Professor Becker von der Allianz der
Wissenschaftsorganisationen sieht ein
Bedarf von bis zu drei Milliarden Euro
Professor Stratmann von Max Planck der
gerade einen Nobelpreis für Deutschland
noch mal nach Hause gebracht hat hat
diese Woche im Ausschuss von 100
Millionen Mehrkosten nur für Max-Planck
geredet in den nächsten Jahren bis zu
400 Millionen
und was uns ganz besonders nachdenklich
macht und wovor wir Sorge haben alleine
bei Max Planck ich bleibe in dem
Beispiel 1.000 neue Doktoranden pro Jahr
die eingestellt werden gerade ein neues
Nachwuchsprogramm mit 20 bis 30
Millionen alles Dinge die jetzt in Frage
gestellt werden müssen wahrscheinlich
wenn es keine Finanzierung in dieser
Notlage gibt meine Damen und Herren ist
droht der unwiederbringliche Verlust von
Forschungsergebnissen hier
und dann ist ja die Frage ist das
Problem eigentlich über Nacht gekommen
wir haben bereits am 28 Juli an die
benetzger geschrieben in persona Stefan
Albani und ich wir haben am 3 August
Frau Ministerin Ihnen eine kleine
Anfrage zu dem Thema geschrieben da
haben sie am 29.8 lapidag geantwortet es
gibt in dieser Bundesregierung seit
Monaten Nachtstunden ein Rettungspaket
jagt das nächste drei entlastungspakete
Grundfreibetrag Arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag
Einmalzahlungen für Empfänger
Kinderbonus energiepreispauschalen
Heizkostenzuschuss Homeoffice pauschale
Sparer Pauschbetrag sogar einen
Spitzenausgleich für energieintensive
Unternehmen was ist bisher für Forschung
und Wissenschaft in diesen Paketen
erreicht worden
sie haben es schlicht vergessen es
werden seit Monaten Hilfspakete
geschnürt aber am Ende stehen viele
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
vor einem ganz schwierigen Szenario und
Frau Ministerin das was von ihnen
verlangt wird das was ihre Aufgabe es
ist Schutzpatronin der Forschung zu sein
und das erwarten viele da draußen und
die setzen ihre Hoffnungen in sie es ist
ein gutes Zeichen wenn aufgrund unserer
Debatte heute sie heute endlich jetzt im
Handelsblatt erklärt haben es braucht
auch einen Rettungsschirm für die
Wissenschaft aber Frau Ministerin das
alles am 20 Oktober ist viel zu spät und
viel zu ungewiss weil es eben noch kein
regierungskonsens ist
wir haben den Pakt für Forschung und
Innovation gemacht drei Prozent
Steigerung pro Jahr das ist der letzte
Rettungsanker den die
Wissenschaftsorganisationen gerade haben
sie Frau Ministerin haben uns
vorgehalten wir hätten damit den
Haushalt versteinert noch im Frühjahr
versteinert da frage ich mich natürlich
was waren ihre Ideen für den Haushalt
wenn Sie diese drei Prozent Wachstum als
Versteinerung gesehen haben ich will es
mir gar nicht vorstellen dati und
staatschancen ihre beiden
Lieblingsprogramme sind alle in weiter
Ferne und wer weiß ob sie nicht an
diesen Haushaltszahlen hätten kratzen
wollen um hier schneller das zu
realisieren und die Priorität muss darin
bestehen Sicherheit und Zuverlässigkeit
für das Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftssystem in Deutschland zu
geben
und wir haben das getan als wir vor zwei
Jahren in der schwierigen corona-phase
waren da wurden nicht nur
entlastungspakete gemacht sondern da
haben wir auch ein 15 Milliarden Paketen
nur für den Bereich BMWF gemacht alleine
die 9 Milliarden zum Wasserstoff mit
denen sie sich auch schmücken stammen
aus den corona-programmen zwei
Milliarden plus quantencomputing Mittel
für die künstliche Intelligenz und
vieles mehr und deshalb ist das was wir
jetzt brauchen und das haben wir hier
heute beantragt wir brauchen ein
Entlastungspaket für die Wissenschaft
darin muss drin sein geschützte Kunden
immer noch sind die
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen unsicher ob sie
in einer Mangellage nicht abgeschaltet
werden müssen sie müssen als geschützte
Kunden definiert werden wir brauchen zum
zweiten eine genaue Bedarfsanalyse
welche Einrichtungen haben welche
Energieverbräuche und können Sie selber
nicht einsparen und was muss ein solches
Paket leisten wir brauchen für einen
Notfallfonds einen
energiepreisdeckelwissenschaft und die
Zahl der Promotionsvorhaben darf nicht
sinken dafür braucht es eine Verabredung
mit den Ländern meine Damen und Herren
das ist heute die Chance für Sie als
Regierung endlich die Rolle einzunehmen
als Schutzpatron der Wissenschaft Frau
Ministerin tun Sie was es ist aller
aller höchste Zeit unsere Wissenschaft
ist in Gefahr es liegt in ihren Händen
jetzt endlich zu handeln
Thomas hier zumbek hat den Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion vorgestellt kurz
zusammengefasst es solle ein notfallfond
für die Wissenschaft her gemeinsam mit
den Ländern soll ein Entlastungspaket
für die Wissenschaft der Arbeit werden
und der nächste Redner kommt von der SPD
Holger Mann sehr sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ob die ionen- und
elektronenquellen am leibnitz-institut
für oberflächenmodifizierung oder auch
die Kühlkammern oder dna-sequenzierer
mit Bioproben am Max-Planck-Institut für
evolutionäre Anthropologie und an der
Stelle sei gesagt Herr jasonbeck weil
sie den Nobelpreis gerade jemand anders
zugesprochen haben das war schon 20
PayPal der die Forschung leistete die
ihm den Nobelpreis einbrachte und damit
sicherlich auch der Max-Planck-Institut
in dieser Stelle hier auch noch mal
Glückwunsch an ihn und die
Forschungsorganisation
ob im Gewächshaus des deutschen Zentrums
für integrative Biodiversitätsforschung
ob im Lesesaal der deutschen Bücherei
oder auch in ihrem Archiv ja überall
brauchen Forscher und
Wissenschaftlerinnen Energie um ihre
Arbeit vorzusetzen oder auch nur um die
Forschungsgegenstände konservieren zu
können sowie an diesen vier
Forschungsinstitutionen im Nordosten von
Leipzig steigen gerade in ganz
Deutschland die Kosten für Strom und
Wärme kurzum natürlich auch die
Wissenschaft ist stark betroffen und
braucht Unterstützung in der
energiepreiskrise
und deshalb sage ich hier vorne deutlich
die SPD steht dafür dass
Forschungseinrichtung von der Gaspreis
und strompreisbremse profitieren
der für die Bundestagsfraktion hat genau
dies bereits am 2 september in ihrem
Positionspapier die Krise solidarisch
meistern beschlossen und nach den
folgenden koalitionsbeschlüssen ist die
Gaspreis und strompreisbremse nun in
Vorbereitung und das ist wirklich gut so
der Stelle sei auch schon mal gesagt
auch wenn uns das morgen noch mal
beschäftigen wird wir können alle morgen
im Bundestag mit dem Beschluss zum
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds selbst
einen Beitrag dazu leisten dass dies
schnell auf den Weg kommt
bin
zudem dankbar dass gerade erst am
Dienstag bei ackertech der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz eindeutig klar gemacht hat
natürlich fallen auch die
Forschungseinrichtungen unter die
Regelung der Gaspreis und zukünftigen
strompreisbremse
und wenn bisher schon galt Julian never
walk alone geht jetzt erst recht Juwel
never du research on you
die Wissenschaft ist also weder von der
Wirtschaft noch von der Gesellschaft
entkoppelt und kann sich daher darauf
verlassen dass wir gemeinsam solidarisch
die energiepreiskrise bewältigen die
Bundesregierung bereitet deshalb die
systemische Unterstützung per Gaspreis
und strompreisbremse vor und das halte
ich auch für richtig weil viele
Einzellösungen uns zu viel Zeit kosten
werden und dass der richtige Ansatz ist
und ich finde auch die Voraussetzung
dafür dass die schnell bei
Forschungseinrichtungen ankommt sind
gegeben die meisten Forschungsinstitute
haben eben einen großen
energiepreisanbieter mit langfristigem
Verträgen das Andocken an die Gaspreise
und strompreisbremse ist also im
Vergleich relativ einfach zu realisieren
wie eben auch bei großen
Industrieunternehmen zudem handelt es
sich hier nicht um gewinnen sondern um
gemeinwohlorientierte Einrichtung es
muss also auch niemand befürchten oder
gar unterstellen das subventionierte
Energie weiterverkauft wird an dieser
Stelle glaube ich ist dieses Instrument
geeignet um die Energiekosten abzufinden
darüber hinaus das haben sie ja gerade
auch noch mal gewürdigt haben sich eben
Bund und leidender im Pakt für
forschunginformationen langfristig zu
kontinuierlichen aufwüchsen der
Forschungsgemeinschaften verpflichtet
und da sei zumindest gesagt die vier
großen Forschungsgemeinschaften haben
aktuell mehrere hundert Millionen Euro
Rücklagen und wir können ja auch mal
stolz sagen sie haben auch das Know-how
und das Personal weitere
Effizienzgewinne zu heben
für die SPD kann ich zudem sagen wir
erwarten von der GWK am dritten November
weitere Einigungen zwischen Bund und
Ländern für die finanzielle
Unterstützung des gesamten
Wissenschaftssystems
ich halte daher bei allen notwendigen
Problembewusstsein und Krisenbekämpfung
nichts von Panikmacher um
existenzbedrohungen wie in ihrem Antrag
formuliert geht es derzeit wirklich in
anderen Bereichen dennoch ich gebe Ihnen
an eine Stelle recht das BMBF wird
stärker den Dialog mit den
unterschiedlichen
Forschungseinrichtungen führen müssen
insbesondere was die Vorsorge für den
Risikovorsorge für den Fall einer
stromnotlage angeht
ich will zum Schluss zumindest noch kurz
darauf hinweisen dass wir neben all den
institutionellen Vorkehrungen auch auf
individuelle Ebene schon einiges getan
haben bereits mit mehreren
entlastungspaketen konkret mit dem
Heizkostenzuschuss 1 und ab heute auch
mit dem Heizkostenzuschuss 2 hoffe ich
doch das heißt mit der Einmalzahlung mit
dem BAföG-Erhöhung oder dem neuen
notfallmechanismus direkte finanzielle
Unterstützung gibt es eben darüber auch
für Lernende und forschende und ich will
hier festhalten wir werden im Verbund
mit den Ländern alles Notwendige tun den
Betrieb für die Bildungs- und
Forschungseinrichtungen zu sichern und
damit Zukunft für unser Land und die
Wissenschaft danke schön
Deutschlands energieintensivstes
Forschungszentrum ist das Desi deutsche
Elektronen synchron in Hamburg so heißt
es 152 GB Stunden verbraucht es dieses
Jahr wenn es nur 20% weniger bezahlen
kann im nächsten Jahr das würde bedeuten
ein ganzer Monat weniger Messzeit für
Vorstellungen Forscher jährlich nutzen
3000 Wissenschaftler die Anlage 250 von
ihnen käme mich zum Zug so sind die
realen Probleme in Einzelprojekten Mark
jungen jetzt von der AFD gesprochen und
zwar von politischen Illusionen und
Ideologien mit der Realität die
Illusionen sind überaus hartnäckig wie
wir bis stürzt feststellen müssen aber
das Realitätsprinzip ist härter und es
wird eine nach der anderen zum platzen
bringen es ist nur noch eine Frage der
kurzen Zeit meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland ist mittlerweile so
heruntergewirtschaftet von den
wechselnden Illusionisten auf der
Regierungsbank dass wir allen Ernstes
darüber diskutieren welche
Wirtschaftszweige welche
Bevölkerungsgruppen oder jetzt welche
Forschungsstätten demnächst noch Strom
und Heizung haben und wo beides
abgeschaltet werden muss ich frage Sie
alle merken Sie eigentlich noch in
welchen Abgrund Sie dieses Land hinein
manövrieren von einer führenden
Industrienation zum Industriemuseum wenn
es so weitergeht meine Damen und Herren
heute fordert die CDU von der Ampel ein
Entlastungspaket und ein notfallfond für
die Wissenschaft die in der Tat in den
Energiekosten zu ersticken droht am
Forschungszentrum Jülich rechnet man
dieses Jahr mit Mehrkosten von
40%, 2023 könnten sich die Energiekosten
verdoppeln dann wird am Personal gespart
werden müssen vor allem junge
Wissenschaftler werden ihre Stellen
verlieren ein großer Blackout hätte
existenzbedrohende Folgen für die
Forschung allein schon wegen der
ausfallenden Datensicherung
aber der Brandstifter ruft doch hier
nach der feuerwehrwerte CDU denn sie
sind ja selbst maßgeblich verantwortlich
für diese Misere es war die
schwarz-gelbe Koalition und der
Kanzlerin Merkel die 20.11 Ausstieg aus
der Kernenergie beschlossen hat und es
war Merkel die Deutschland hochgradig
abhängig von russischem Gas gemacht hat
zusammen mit der SPD haben Sie dann den
Grünen windradwahn ins Werk gesetzt der
ein energiepolitisches Lustschloss war
und ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
weil die Windkraft eben nicht
grundlastfähig ist und sie fordern ja
auch jetzt nur mit großen Tamtam die
Laufzeitverlängerung aber halten
prinzipiell am Ausstieg aus der
Kernkraft fest das ist doch armselig und
ideenlos jetzt stellen sie plötzlich die
Kurzatmigkeit der aktuellen Bekämpfung
der Energiekrise fest und fordern eine
langfristige Strategie für sichere und
bezahlbare Energieversorgung ohne eine
einzige Idee in ihrem Antrag auch nur
anzudeuten worin diese Strategie
bestehen könnte das muss man erstmal
fertig bringen dabei liegt es auf der
Hand dass es nur um die Rückkehr zur
Kernenergie und die Beendigung der
Russland Sanktionen gehen kann meine
Damen und Herren hören Sie auch bitte
auf mit der abgeschmackten Ausrede Putin
und der Krieg sein an allem Schuld nein
deutsche Zahlen mit die höchsten
Strompreise weltweit beim Gas doppelt so
viel wie unsere polnischen Nachbarn und
etwa dreimal so viel wie in Ungarn nicht
wegen des kriegesinn der Ukraine der hat
die hausgemachten Probleme nur
verschärft sondern wegen der dümmsten
Energiepolitik der Welt wie das Wort
Journal treffen schrieb nämlich der
deutschen und es rächt sich jetzt bitter
dass man in Deutschland die
ingenieurskompetenz in Sachen Kernkraft
systematisch zerstört hat auf Betreiben
der Grünen Ideologen hier und das auf
der politische Druck auf die
Wissenschaft kaum noch eine
wissenschaftliche offen öffentliche
offene Diskussion über die Ursachen des
Klimawandels und den Umgang damit
zulässt wir müssen wegkommen von dem
doma der Weltrettung von Deutschland aus
und stattdessen hören Sie doch mal
besser zu kreative Ideen entwickeln wie
wir uns an höhere Temperaturen und
wechselnde Wetterlagen anpassen können
ohne unsere Wirtschaft und aktuell sogar
unser Wissenschaftssystem massiv zu
schädigen da können auch große Chancen
daraus erwachsen die afd-fraktion ich
komme zum Schluss ist für die prioritäre
Stromversorgung wichtiger
Forschungseinrichtungen im akuten
Krisenfall aber wir sehen darin nur eine
hilflose krisenbekämpfer
Symptombekämpfung wir brauchen die
energiepolitische Wende jetzt bevor es
zur Katastrophe kommt vielen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über einen
Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion Notfallfonds
für das Wissenschaftssystem
nächste Rednerin Laura Kraft für die
bündnisgründen sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich denke wir alle sind uns in
einer Sache einig Wissenschaft und
Innovation gehen Hand in Hand und die
wissen ohne Wissenschaft gäbe ist kein
Fortschritt und wir müssen jetzt auch
die Hochschulen und auch die
Forschungseinrichtungen in unserem Land
schützen Wissenschaft ist der Schlüssel
für die Überwindung von Krise und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt hier mehr tun
in
in dieser aktuellen Krise ist das
Wissenschaftssystem von enormen
Energiepreisen betroffen und muss auch
über den Winter kommen und darum müssen
wir Forschungseinrichtungen universitäre
wie auch außeruniversitäre während der
Krise unterstützen und gerade deshalb
hat das BMBF bereits beim Bundeskanzler
für geworben das Wissenschaft auch aber
auch
energieintensive Forschungseinrichtungen
im wirtschaftlichen Abwehr share
geschirrabwehrschirm Entschuldigung der
Bundesregierung berücksichtigt werden es
ist erklärteste der Ampel das
Wissenschaftssystem unbedingt zu
schützen und ich bin froh dass wir heute
über die Bedeutung der Energieversorgung
der Forschungseinrichtungen diskutieren
der Antrag der Union enthält
schlussforderungen die so nicht ganz
richtig sind wir wollen auf keinen Fall
dass es zu irgendwelchen Schäden kommt
wie etwa an unwiederbringlichen
biodatenbanken oder das Tiere in
Tierhäusern zu Schaden kommen oder dass
irgendwelche Daten verloren gehen das
wollen wir natürlich nicht und da werden
wir auch alles für tun dass das nicht
passiert wir nehmen die kritische Lage
äußerst ernst und wir arbeiten mit
hochdruckanlösungen
Entlastung mit besonderem Fokus auf
Bildung und Wissenschaft die müssen
jetzt folgen und das werden sie auch es
darf jedoch nicht sein dass Hochschulen
wieder befürchten müssen ausschließlich
in den Online-Betrieb zurückzukehren und
die Kosten die dann wohl möglich bei den
Hochschulen eingespart werden die landen
ja dann wieder bei den Studierenden und
die haben in der Pandemie ja nun
wirklich am meisten zurückgesteckt
die Situation der Kostensteigerung muss
im Gesamtpaket betrachtet werden
Unterstützung muss auch bei den
Hochschulen den Mensen und den
studierendenwerken ankommen dabei hoffe
ich auf gute Zusammenarbeit mit den
Ländern die hierbei auch gefragt sind
Unterstützung der Studierenden ist im
Bereich Verpflegung und Wohnen von
immenser Bedeutung denn das sind mit die
größten Kostenpunkte die Studierende
haben die Mieten in Wohnheim steigen
teilweise deutlich mein Wahlkreise einen
der Uni Siegen werden ab Januar zum
Beispiel die Wohnheim mieten um 70 bis
100 Euro pro Monat angehoben
gleichzeitig wird aber oftmals auch das
Essen in den Mensen teurer das kann man
natürlich auch verstehen weil die Mensen
natürlich auch mehr Kosten haben durch
die lebensmittelpreissteigerung und
damit Studierende sich nicht entscheiden
müssen zwischen warmer Wohnung oder
warmer Mahlzeit dann muss nach der
strompreisbremse dann auch die
mensa-preisbremse kommen
die Frage wo gespart wird wo nicht die
ist eben in dieser Zeit von großer
Bedeutung und teilweise besteht ein sehr
gutes Einsparpotenzial und darum freut
mich die Nachricht dass viele
Hochschulen das Ziel verfolgen 15 bis 20
Prozent an Energieeinsparen zu wollen
das ist aber an anderen Stellen
schwierig und wenn Einrichtungen ihre
Forschung nicht weiter betreiben können
dann handeln wir uns Probleme mit
langfristigen Konsequenzen ein denn
Forschung ist eben ein großer
Innovationstreiber in Deutschland und
die gesellschaftlichen und die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen bei Einschnitten
in der Wissenschaft die wären verheerend
Wissenschaft braucht Finanzierung
Sicherheit Stabilität und dafür stehen
wir ein dafür setzen wir uns ein vielen
Dank
für die Fraktion
für Forschung Technologie und
Innovationspolitik für ihre Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ja wir Wissenschaft und Forschung ist
die Lage gerade wirklich ernst viele in
der Wissenschaft Einrichtungen genauso
wie forschende und Studierende sind mit
explodierenden verpreisen ohne Frage
überfordert da stimme ich den Kollegen
zu Energiekrise und Inflationen Folgen
nunmehr auf fast- oder gut zwei Jahre
Pandemie und in dieser Zeit sind schon
Forschungsprojekte weggerutscht Lehrende
und Lernende haben sich aufgeräumt um
wissenschafts-
auch Studierenden sind in dieser Zeit
Nebenjobs verloren gegangen ohne das
wirklich geholfen wurde also
Tatenlosigkeit in der Krise kennt man
nicht erst von dieser Regierung so weit
so schlecht was ist zu bedenken was ist
zu tun erstens ich will das breiter
aufstellen als dass der Kollege von der
CDU gemacht hat Hochschulen brauchen
dringend Unterstützung damit der lehr-
und Forschungsbetrieb ohne Einschränkung
weitergehen kann und das haben sie auch
versprochen Hochschulen sind aber eben
auch seit Jahren unterfinanziert und das
belastet längst Studierende und
beschäftigte noch ein Winter mit
eingeschränkter Präsenz diesmal aber
weil es zu kalt ist müssen wir unbedingt
verhindern
zweitens
ich will nicht irgendeine mensa-bremse
ich rede über das Deutsche Studentenwerk
deutsche Studierendenwerk die wir nicht
auf den Energiekosten sitzen lassen
können klar wie sollen denn Mensen sonst
offen gehalten werden aber umgekehrt wie
sollen den beispielsweise auch
Studierendenwohnheime erschwinglich
betrieben werden und eben dann auch
vermietet werden können und dort erleben
wir bereits jetzt Mietsteigerungen von
60 Euro sie können ja selber mal rechnen
wie weit man beispielsweise dabei auf
den Heizkostenzuschuss zugreifen kann
der ja eigentlich noch nicht mal
originär für die Miete gedacht ist also
es muss mehr passieren da stimme ich nun
wiederum der Kollegin zu drittens das
ist noch nicht erwähnt worden aber da
haben wir da brennt wirklich der Baum
viele
universitätskliniker können derzeit
nicht sagen wie sie ihren Betrieb
weiterführen sollen wenn Energiepreise
tatsächlich um bis zu 400% steigen auch
Sachmittel Lebensmittel medizinischer
Bedarf sind um gut 30% gestiegen auch
diese dürfen wir nicht allein lassen es
sind ja auch
ausbildungskrankenhäuser bzw
Maximalversorger 4
Kliniken wie Hochschulen fällt jetzt der
Sanierungsstau doppelt auf die Füße
allein durch unikliniker in meinem
Bundesland Sachsen-Anhalt haben ein
Sanierungsbedarf von 1,5 Milliarden
bundesweit sind es aber 35 bis 60
Milliarden Sanierungsstau klar in also
Energie Ineffizienz wird das Thema
bleiben gerade eben bei Gebäuden und
deshalb meine Damen und Herren machen
Sie endlich den Hochschulbau wieder zu
einer Gemeinschaftsaufgabe von Bund und
Ländern das war damals ein Fehler es
abzuschaffen
fünftens und letztens
sie haben es richtig gesagt Hochschulen
sollen als geschützte Einrichtung gelten
das ist die richtige Entscheidung das
ist seit 1.9 diesen Jahres geklärt geben
sie aber auch den studierendenwerken
diesen Schutzstatus und für beide meine
Damen und Herren muss zwingend die
gaspreisbremse gelten klar Herr
jazzombeck selbstverständlich muss die
Klärung auch herbeigelführt werden für
außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen da stimme ich
Ihnen völlig zu aber schließlich muss
auch der Zukunftsvertrag Studium und
Lehre den steigenden Preisen angepasst
werden die Hilfen sind natürlich nicht
kosten neutral wer das glaubt erzählt
hier Murks und mist das ist alles Unsinn
natürlich müssen wir dort dran natürlich
müssen wir mit den Ländern verhandeln ob
das für den Pakt für Forschung und
Innovation auch notwendig ist wird sich
erweisen bei den Gesprächen mit den
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen also wir sollten
uns nichts vormachen wir sollten ehrlich
sein und wir sollten in diese
Verhandlung eintreten um dann eben auch
den Hochschulen den studierendenwerken
den unikliniker und den universitären
Forschungseinrichtungen unter die Arme
zu greifen danke für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
für die FDP-Fraktion spricht Prof dr
Stefan Seiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute über den Antrag der CDU zum Thema
Entlastungspaket und Notfall vor
einrichten um Schaden vom deutschen
Wissenschaftssystem abzuwenden das ist
ein aktueller und relevanter Antrag und
es geht in der Tat um unser
Wissenschaftssystem das international
eine Spitzenstellung einnimmt und wir
haben es jetzt schon dann verschiedene
Stelle gehört das Wissenschaftssystem
alle Beteiligten dieses Systems haben in
den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren zwei
dreivierteljahren sind mittlerweile
große Leistungen gebracht und dafür
sollten wir alle gemeinsam dankbar sein
und da teile ich ihre Einschätzung liebe
Kolleginnen das Frau Sitte dass wir da
nicht genug danken können es waren
extrem schwierige Bedingungen und die
Bedingungen dürfen jetzt nicht
schwieriger werden das ist auf jeden
Fall klar
Aktualität und Relevanz sind aber
letztendlich nicht zwingend das was eine
zielorientierte und lösungsorientierte
Vorgehensweise begründet vielmehr müssen
wir uns Gedanken noch mal drüber machen
was sind die Ursachen und ich denke wir
sind uns ja alle einig im Haus wie so
vielleicht eine kleine Gruppe zu meiner
Rechten dass der Ursache der putinische
Angriffskrieg ist damit müssen wir klar
anerkennen die Ursache liegt dort und
der zweite Sache die wir anerkennen
müssen ist natürlich dass wir in der
Vergangenheit eine Energiepolitik
gemacht haben die zu stark auf die
Abhängigkeit einzelner großen
Lieferanten gesetzt hat das sind aber
Dinge die werden wir kurzfristig so
nicht lösen können sondern kurzfristig
drückt die Aussehen universitären
Forschungseinrichtungen die
Universitäten die Hochschulen das
Problem gestiegener Energiepreise
gestiegener weiterer Kosten wir haben
noch das Thema Information wir haben
auch das Thema das natürlich Inflation
durchaus auch zu Lohnforderungen führen
wird im Tarifbereich die Hochschulen die
Universitäten die
Forschungseinrichtungen stehen vor
diesem Problem und wir müssen uns
darüber im Klaren werden wie wir dieses
Thema angehen
niemand wird in diesem Haus bereit sein
das Wissenschaftssystem so zu gefährden
dass wichtige Daten wichtige Zellproben
wichtige burkanne verloren gehen und wir
sind uns alle darüber einig dass wir in
diesem Fall aktiv werden müssen und das
ist das was mich jetzt zum Beispiel am
Antrag der CDU etwas stört nämlich es
wird von einer Tatenlosigkeit gesprochen
diese Tatenlosigkeit ist nicht gegeben
die Ministerin setzt sich für das
Wissenschaftssystem ein wir haben das
Faktum heute da zum Beispiel nachlesbar
im Handelsblatt dass die Ministerin
fordert dass die außenuniversitären
Einrichtungen in den Abwehrschirm oder
hinter den Abwehrschirm genommen werden
die außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen haben große
Rücklagen sie sind bereit diese
Rücklagen abzubauen das ist das
solidarische Beitrag dieser
Institutionen
aber sie werden und das ist unsere
unterstützen wir sehr in diesen
Abwehrschirm übernommen werden müssen
die Schule und Hochschulen sind
auch als geschützte Kunden auf der Liste
sie werden das werden darüber haben so
wir wissen die Ministerin für Forschung
und Bildung und der Wirtschaftsminister
sich ausgetauscht und es gibt wohl auch
dort in die Richtung dass es gut wird
und es weichste was natürlich die Sache
ist die Hochschulen bereiten
Notfallpläne vor sie nehmen
Sparmaßnahmen das ist der Beitrag der
Hochschulen es darf aber nicht passieren
dass die Hochschulen dann wieder aus dem
präsenzbetrieb herausgehen weil das
wollen wir sicher hier in diesem Haus
alle gemeinsam nicht aber wir wissen
auch das Spielraum für die Hochschulen
ist begrenzt es gibt ein Sparpotenzial
aber dieses Sparpotenzial ist endlich
das wurde auch schon an verschiedener
Stelle angesprochen und da kommt jetzt
der nächste Spieler letztendlich auf den
Platz und dieser nächste Spieler das
sind die Länder und da ist schon die
Frage erlaubt was haben die Länder
bisher getan um deren Hochschulen zu
helfen einzelne Länder haben schon
Einstellungen gemacht in den Haushalt
andere Länder sind noch im such- und
Findungsprozess und es gibt auch Länder
ich schaue ich sie wissen ich komme aus
Baden-Württemberg ich schaue in Richtung
mein östlichen Nachbar die haben bisher
gar nichts gemacht und warten auf den
Bund bzw schieben es auf den Bund da so
können wir diese Krise nicht angehen und
lösen und so lassen wir letztendlich
unser Hochschulsystem allein die Länder
haben einen Haushalt tierischen
Spielraum sie sind Träger der Hochschule
und sie dürfen sich nicht immer nur mit
den Leistungen in tollen Ergebnissen der
Hochschulen schmücken und wenn sie Not
geraten dann trägt man jemand anderem
dann ruft man nach der großen Schwester
oder der Schutzpatronin wie das Kollege
ja zumbek vorher gesagt hat
dann haben die
ministeraustausch mit den Stakeholdern
ansonsten hätte es diese Maßnahmen diese
Aktivitäten letztendlich nicht gegeben
die Koalition bekennt sich zum Schutz
des Wissenschaftssystem wir haben viele
Maßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht
dankenswerterweise hat Kollege a zumbeck
die alle aufgeführt so dass ich es hier
an dieser Stelle nicht mehr tun muss und
wir seien Sie versichert gemeinsam
werden wir das meistern wir werden aber
die Solidarität aller Beteiligten
brauchen um eben diesen Weg zu gehen um
das Bildungssystem zu sichern denn und
damit komme ich zum Schluss unser
Wissenschaftssystem ist Garant dafür
dass wir technologische Souveränität
wieder erreichen können dass wir im
systemwettbewerb der sich international
ergeben hat auch wieder eine starke
Position einnehmen müsste und das müsste
Grund für uns alle gemeinsam sein
gemeinsam ohne Polemik in diesem Feld
nach vorne zu gehen vielen Dank
Stefan Seite war das für die FDP der
Bundestag der debattiert über ein Antrag
der cdu/csu-fraktion Notfallfonds für
das Wissenschaftssystem und die
zuständige stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Union Nadine
schön erhält jetzt das Wort sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen das Problem über das wir heute
diskutieren das fällt ja wahrlich nicht
vom Himmel seit Monaten diskutieren wir
in Deutschland darüber wie wir mit
dieser Energiekrise umgehen und was uns
alle frustriert ist dass diese
Bundesregierung nach wie vor kein
Gesamtkonzept vorliegt wie sie die
exorbitanten Energiekosten Steigerungen
bewältigt und wie sie auch auf der
Angebotsseite dafür sorgt dass wir mehr
Energie in unser Land bekommen auch
heute nicht
und was uns besonders schmerzt ist dass
die Auswirkungen auf Wissenschaft und
Forschung enorm sind und das hat diese
Debatte deutlich gezeigt wir haben bei
den Forschungs- und den
wissenschaftssituation Einrichtungen die
Situation dass sie mit Blackouts
schlicht nicht leben können es wird IRA
parabler Schaden entstehen wenn die
Energieversorgung bei gewissen
Instituten ganz ausfällt und auch die
enormen Energiekosten Steigerung
teilweise wird um das wird über das
zweieinhalbfach gesprochen können die
Einrichtungen nicht alleine schultern
die Erkenntnis ist da zumindest bei uns
schon lange und deshalb sind wir sehr
früh tätig geworden wir haben im Juli
bereits den Präsident der
Bundesnetzagentur angeschrieben und
haben gefragt wie sieht es denn aus mit
den Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen sind die denn
gedeckt von diesem Schutzschirm
und die Antwort war der Kollege gerdin
sagt ja die Antwort war nein
Hochschulen ich kann sogar zitieren aus
der Antwort von 29 auch aus der Antwort
vom Juli
und Hochschulen gehören zu den
geschützten Kunden nicht aber
Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen wir haben
daraufhin die Bundesregierung
angeschrieben und haben gefragt ob sie
denn mal mit der Bundesnetzagentur in
den Austausch gehen und ob sie sich
nicht dafür einsetzen wollen dass die
Energiesicherheit gewährleistet ist bei
den Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen und die
Antwort
führt die Bundesregierung hat die
Versorgungssicherheit der Forschung eine
hohe Bedeutung und ein
Versorgungsengpass in diesem Bereich
hätte weitreichende Folgen das BMBF ist
hierzu im Austausch mit dem
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz der Bundesnetzagentur sowie
mit den wissenschaftsakteuren ein
Austausch am 29 August 2022 wir haben
aber jetzt Mitte Oktober und jetzt
können Sie hier ganz entspannt sagen das
sind doch erst zwei Monate her uns läuft
die Zeit davon jeder einzelne Tag ist
wichtig um eine Lösung zu finden und wir
haben in diesen zwei Monaten keine einz
Lösung gehört keine einzige und heute
heute das ist die Lösung heute kündigt
die Bundesministerin im Handelsblatt an
dass Sie sich für einen Rettungsschirm
für
spitzenforschungseinrichtungen einsetzt
heute wo unser Antrag hier im Plenum
debattiert wird das ist ja erstmal schön
wir hätten uns über ein paar mehr
Details zu diesem Antrag gefreut die
Ministerin kann ich sprechen sie muss
jetzt heute in den Haushaltsausschuss
aber es hätte doch andere Wege gegeben
als eine Kachel bei Twitter des BMBF ich
hätte mich auch für die Einrichtungen
gefreut wenn wir mehr Details über
diesen Rettungsschirm heute erfahren
halten
und jetzt wünschen wir der Ministerin
natürlich viel Glück bei ihren
Verhandlungen im Haushaltsausschuss
vielleicht geht es auch genau um diese
Themen toi toi toi aber die Dynamik
dieser Debatte lässt mich nicht glauben
dass die Koalition in Gänze sich dafür
einst ist einsetzt dass hier sehr
schnell was passiert Frau Kraft sagt
zwar wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck
anlösungen und anderen sagen auch dass
der Bedarf da ist aber Fakt ist dass der
Winter jetzt ist und die gaspreisbremse
greift im Frühjahr und fährt die
Einrichtungen ist für den Winter keine
Vorsorge getroffen nicht bei Blackouts
nicht bei exorbitant steigenden Kosten
wir erwarten heute Lösungen heute hätten
sie die Chance gehabt in deutschen im
Plenum dieses Deutschen Bundestages
diese zu präsentieren sie haben es nicht
getan
deshalb haben wir
Ihnen heute diesen Antrag vorgelegt wir
fordern ganz konkret und Sie können sich
einfach an unserem Antrag orientieren
wir fordern dass die
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen von der
Bundesnetzagentur als geschützte Kunden
eingestuft werden
wir fordern ganz konkret einen
Entlastungspaket für die Wissenschaft um
den drohenden Schaden für uns zu
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen abzuwenden
wir fordern ganz konkret eine
Notfallfonds denn wenn Energie
eingespart werden muss
dann muss das irgendwo wenn wenn Energie
bezahlt werden muss dann muss ein
anderer Stelle gespart werden und das
hat enorme Folgen für das Gesamtsystem
Wissenschaft und Forschung darunter
Leitern die Doktoranden darunter leiten
die das Wissenschaftssystem insgesamt
und das müssen wir verhindern da waren
wir uns ja auch heute einig und wir
fordern dass die Bundesregierung
schnellstmöglich zu einem Energiegipfel
für die Wissenschaft einlädt damit all
diese Themen zügig in trockene Tücher
gepackt werden können folgen Sie uns am
Antrag stimmen Sie mit unserem Antrag
wir haben konkrete Vorschläge gemacht
nicht erst heute sondern seit Juli und
das ist ein leichtes dem zu folgen wir
erweitern nicht nur schöne Tweets und
nicht nur schöne Reden im Deutschen
Bundestag sondern ganz konkrete Taten
Nadine schön und die Union fordert in
diesem Antrag unter anderem ja einen
Notfallfonds für die Wissenschaft und
Nadine schön hat es angesprochen heute
meldet das Handelsblatt dass Ministerin
Bettina starke Watzinger die
Bundesforschungsministerin einen
Rettungsschirm für
spitzenforschungseinrichtungen fordert
für die SPD jetzt Oliver Kaczmarek wir
müssen einordnen was muss man
grundsätzlich tun in dieser
energiepreiskrise was muss nur ein
spezifisch für die Wissenschaft tun und
was heißt das eigentlich für
langfristige Perspektiven der
Wissenschaft und Frau schön ich muss
sagen ich habe etwas anderen Eindruck
was die Schnelligkeit im Handeln angeht
weil bei der grundsätzlichen Bearbeitung
der Frage wie wir mit der Krise umgehen
geht es darum vier Punkte und die
Versorgungslage die gesichert werden
muss es geht um Preise die gebremst
werden müssen es geht darum zu helfen
mit Entlastungen und es geht darum
Energie einzusparen und du musst noch
mal ganz ehrlich sagen
während ihre Fraktion hier noch so
Sachen wie gasmoratorien gefordert hat
ist die Bundesregierung losgegangen und
hat dafür gesorgt dass wir lng-terminals
bauen das Speicher geführt werden dass
eine neue lieferantengas liefern und
damit dafür gesorgt dass überhaupt
Forschung betrieben werden kann im
nächsten Winter während ihre Fraktion
dann noch im Tiefschlaf gelegen hat also
da bin ich nicht ihrer Meinung
vor dem Hintergrund dieser vier
Herausforderungen die wir allgemein und
für alle und damit auch für Wissenschaft
und Forschung zu lösen haben müssen wir
natürlich über die spezifischen Bedarfe
von Wissenschaft und Forschung sprechen
was sind die genauen Bedarfe was sind
basisbedarfe beim Energieverbrauch
welche zusätzlichen Bedarfe müssen
abgedeckt werden und wo kann überhaupt
Energie gespart werden die Hochschulen
haben sich auf den Weg gemacht aber wir
wissen es gibt Forschungseinrichtungen
nicht nur tiersammlungen sondern auch
andere wo überhaupt keine Energie
eingespart werden kann weil die Anlagen
durchlaufen müssen und deswegen müssen
wir darauf aufbauend im Dialog mit den
außeruniversitären
Forschungsorganisation mit den
Hochschulen auch passgenaue Lösungen
finden für die Wissenschaft und ich bin
der Meinung die Expertenkommission Gas
wir haben hat da schon Ideen auch
geliefert mit denen wir uns auch
auseinandersetzen können und wo wir auch
um eine schnelle Umsetzung bemüht sind
es geht darum zu überprüfen wie wir den
fuel Switch also den Umstieg auf andere
Energieträger finanziell unterstützen
können wie wir härtefallfonds
möglicherweise brauchen nur ich will
eins sagen das ist nicht eine
Herausforderung an die Bundesregierung
sondern es geht an mehrere Akteure und
ich habe gestern im Ausschuss gehört
dass der Präsident der
Max-Planck-Gesellschaft gesagt hat dass
er sich diese Herausforderung sehr wohl
bewusst ist dass die
Forschungsorganisation ein Beitrag
leisten müssen und ich habe einen
kleinen Tipp sie sind ja auch an einigen
Landesregierungen beteiligt heute findet
die Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz statt
vielleicht haben Sie ja in ihren Ländern
wo sie auch in der Regierung sind den
Hinweis auch gegeben darauf dass wir
Forschungseinrichtungen in besonderer
Weise schützen müssen wenn das gelingt
dann bin ich mir sicher werden wir auch
eine gute Lösung gemeinsam mit den
Ländern finden und mit den
Forschungseinrichtungen
und mein Kollege Holger Mann hat gerade
schon gesagt der Bundeskanzler selbst
hat in dieser Woche bei der
Festveranstaltung der ackertech deutlich
gemacht dass die Bundesregierung dieses
Problem nicht nur sieht sondern dass sie
an konkreten Lösungen arbeitet im Dialog
mit dem Forschungsorganisation mit den
Ländern und die
Wissenschaftsorganisationen in diesem
Land wissen dass solch eine Rede nicht
daher gesprochen ist sondern dass sie
sich auf das Wort des Kanzlers verlassen
können und wie als Regierungskoalition
werden das auch unterstützen
die wichtige Frage die viele umtreibt in
den Forschungsorganisationen ist eine
die längerfristig darüber hinausgeht
natürlich müssen wir die Energiekrise
überwinden aber jeder weiß doch 100
Milliarden für die Bundeswehr 100
Milliarden für entlastungspakete 200
Milliarden für den wirtschaftlichen
Abwehrschirm plus die Belastungen die
wir im Bundeshaushalt haben aus der
corona-pandemie die sind ja nicht weg
das eng die Spielräume für öffentliche
Haushalte ein und viele
Wissenschaftsorganisationen fragen sich
wie geht es eigentlich in dieser lang in
dieser Lage langfristig weiter und ich
will an dieser Stelle sagen dass in den
Fakten und nicht in den Reden der
Oppositionsfraktion ziemlich deutlich
abzulesen ist dass die Priorität für
Bildung und Forschung in dieser
Regierungskoalition in dieser
Bundesregierung erhalten bleibt das
zeigt der Haushalt den wir demnächst
abschließen werden für das nächste Jahr
und das zeigt auch der Pakt für
Forschung und Innovation und ich muss da
schon sagen Herr zombeck und Frau schön
ich war schon sehr irritiert dass ich
heute gelesen habe dass sie der
Bundesregierung unterstellen die
Aufwüchse würden den Fragen erzählt ich
meine das ist im bmbf-haushalt wenig
disponible Mittel gibt das ist eine
Tatsachenfeststellung die viele
Vorgängerinnen von Frau starkwatzinger
auch so getroffen haben auch aus ihrer
Fraktion dass sie daraus aber ableiten
der Aufwuchs der vereinbart worden ist
in der Bund ländervereinbarung von drei
Prozent in jedem Jahr für die
paktorganisation würde damit in Frage
stellen ist eine wirklich absurde
Verdrehung von Tatsachen die hätte ich
Ihnen wirklich nicht zugetraut das muss
man mal ganz ehrlich sagen
ich hätte gedacht sie wissen dass man
eine bundländervereinbarung nicht
einseitig kürzen kann kündigen kann wir
werden in der GWK in dieser in der
nächsten Woche in der übernächsten Woche
glaube ich Entscheidungen haben womit
auch die Wissenschaftsorganisationen bzw
die Hochschulen langfristige
planungsperspektiven erhalten werden und
insofern ist völlig klar und auch gegen
jede Rede der Opposition klar und
nachvollziehbar die Priorität für
Bildung und Forschung bleibt und wir
haben eine Regierungskoalition die sich
in diesen schwierigen Zeiten für unsere
Haushalte für die Gesellschaft aber doch
klar und mit viel Geld und Fakten hinter
unsere Forschungsorganisation stellt
herzlichen Dank
gesagt Oliver Kaczmarek von der SPD die
Kultusminister der Länder übrigens die
stellen sich auch hinter die
Forschungsinstitutionen und die
Forschungseinrichtungen denn die haben
Anfang Oktober bereits eine Forderung
abgegeben dass die Sicherstellung des
präsenzbetriebs an Hochschulen und
Forschungseinrichtungen und
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen auch im Falle
einer gasmangelage gewährleistet werden
sollen
mit diesem Antrag auch deren Schaden den
sie selbst in der Regierung mit
angerichtet hat doch er geht in die
richtige Richtung und benennen treffen
die Problemfelder deshalb ja jetzt
Sonnenweg vielen Dank für den Antrag
unsere Forschungseinrichtungen müssen
bei den ausufernden Energiekosten
deutlich entlastet werden das betrifft
energieintensive
großforschungsvorhaben wie denn
kernfusionsversuchsreaktor Wendelstein
7x oder den teilchenbeschluss
doch auch weniger spektakuläre Anlagen
wie Reinräume
langzeitexperimente in der chemischen
biologischen Forschungen in der
Materialforschung und viele andere
Forschungsvorhaben sind gefährdet
Beispiele wurden heute viele genannt
Monate dauernde Experimente sind umsonst
wenn die Energieversorgung nicht
gewährleistet ist
Forschung braucht Energie zu bezahlbaren
Preisen sonst gehen dort die Lichter aus
mit verheerenden Folgen für die Zukunft
Deutschlands
dies wurde von der Bundesregierung
bisher nicht berücksichtigt warum Werte
Regierungsfraktionen muss solch ein
Antrag erst aus der Opposition kommen
wieso kommen Sie darauf nicht selbst
doch mit einem energiepreisdeckel für
die Forschung ist es nicht getan
Inflation und Energiepreise sind zu
einer schweren Belastung für die
Wissenschaft geworden besserung ist
nicht in Sicht darum muss ich leider
wieder an den unhaltbaren Zustand
erinnern dass das Gesamtbudget des BMBF
für 2023 gegenüber dem laufenden Jahr
quasi stagniert und nicht einmal
ansatzweise die Inflation ausgleicht
selbst wenn morgen der Krieg in der
Ukraine beendet sein sollte wird die
energieversorgungslage keinen Deut
besser sein wie geht es dann weiter
darauf gibt auch der vorliegende Antrag
keine Antwort
Forschung und Wissenschaft sind die
Grundlage unseres Wohlstands und ein
Versprechen an die Zukunft sie müssen in
der materiellen Ausstattung endlich den
Stellenwert bekommen der ihnen zusteht
es ist darüber hinaus festzuhalten dass
die gegenwärtige Krise auch Ausfluss
einer politisch gewollten einseitigen
Ausrichtung der Forschung selbst ist
weil die Forschung an der friedlichen
Nutzung der Kernenergie und
synthetischen Kraftstoffen an neuen
umweltverträglichen Technologien für
Kohle und Gaskraftwerke im
ideologiegebäude dieser aber auch der
Vorgängerregierung keinen Platz hatte
kann Deutschland seine Energiebedarf
nicht aus eigener Kraft decken
ich fordere insbesondere Sie werte
Kollegen von der FDP auf sich wenigstens
in diesem Fall gemeinsam mit der
Opposition für eine Politik der Vernunft
und des Fortschritts einzusetzen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Herr Gehring hat jetzt das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ist der Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Bildung Forschung und Technologie
vollgeabschätzung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe Union zu historischen
Einordnung muss ich dann schon noch mal
sagen sie hätten diesem Land so viel
ersparen können wenn sie uns nicht
energiewirtschaftspolitisch 16 Jahre
abhängig gemacht hätten vom putin-gas
entgegen sämtlicher Warnung der
Friedensforschung von Energieexperten
und der baltischen Staaten das war eben
keine Krisenvorsorge sondern ist eine
der schwersten Hypotheken der
merkeljahre und das trifft eben heute
alle Sektoren die privaten Haushalte die
Wirtschaft und eben auch die
Wissenschaft und ich sage sehr klar für
diese Koalition wir kümmern uns
unser Wissenschaftssystem muss
krisenfester und zukunftsfit werden und
da sage ich auch guten Morgen liebe und
John ist ja schön dass sie mal endlich
auch einen Antrag stellen aber wir haben
ein
ministerpräsidentin-konferenz Beschluss
wir haben ein KMK-Beschluss wir haben
Eckpunkte der gaspreiskommission die
alle darauf abzielen das Hochschulen und
außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen als Herzstücke
unseres Wissenschaftssystems erstens bei
Energiekosten entlastet werden zweitens
Bund und Länder dafür Sorge tragen dass
die Stromversorgung sichergestellt ist
und drittens diese Infrastrukturen des
Wissens von Schulen bis
großforschungseinrichtung als kritische
Infrastrukturen gesehen werden und nach
drei online Semester mit
campus-lockdowns werden wir Blackouts
und Versorgungsengpässe abwenden und
dafür sorgen dass an den Hochschulen
Präsenz wieder die Regel ist
ich sage für meine Fraktion sehr klar
Hochschulen und außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen gehören ins
gaspreisdeckelgesetz sie gehören vom
Bund und Ländern entlastet damit sie
auch gut durch den Winter manövrieren
können und ich kann mir gar nicht anders
vorstellen das ist der
Bundesfinanzminister genauso sieht was
wir nicht brauchen Liebe Union ist ein
wissenschaftsgipfel den sie in ihrem
Antrag vorschlagen wir haben MPK GWK KMK
wir haben ständig gute Gesprächskontakte
zwischen Regierung
koalitionsfraktion und der
Wissenschaftscommunity und wir haben vor
allem ganz viele bottom-up-initiativen
wir haben task forces in den Hochschulen
in den Laboren in den einzelnen
Forschungseinrichtungen die alle dafür
sorgen Energie einzusparen effizienter
zu werden die wollen doch auch in
Zeitalter der Klimagerechtigkeit und das
ist Teil des Schutzschirms den wir
stricken
das Problem ist da aber wir arbeiten
daran ist zu lösen und deshalb brauchen
wir keine schaufensteranträge der Union
wir arbeiten im übrigen weiter
konsequent einer zukunftsgerechteten
Bund Länder wissenschaftsfinanzierung
genau in zwei Wochen wird die gemeinsame
Wissenschaftskonferenz den
Zukunftsvertrag Studium und Lehre
beschließen und auch die Neuausrichtung
der Exzellenzinitiative jahrelang liefen
doch Pakt für Forschung und Innovation
für die außeruniversitären und
Hochschulpakt 1 und 2 für die
Hochschulen aneinander vorbei und hat
sich die Finanzierung entkoppelt das
ändert diese Koalition nicht nur die
außeruniversitären kriegen jährlich drei
Prozent sondern künftig auch die
Hochschulen drei Prozent plus das ist
eine Korrektur eines webfehlers und das
ist eine verlässliche
finanzierungsperspektive für unser
Wissenschaftssystem die Ampel wirkt
und das BMBF und die Ampel bereiten auch
vor die weiteren
koalitionsvertragsprojekte aufzugleichen
tenia
track-programm diversity Digitalisierung
und moderne Governance das muss im
nächsten Jahr bearbeitet werden
Steigerung der programmpauschale können
Sie gerne mitwirken damit die
forschungsstarken Universitäten da auch
entsprechend profitieren denn unsere
Peilung ist klar das 3,5 Prozent sie für
Forschung und Entwicklung ist wichtig
damit die 20er Jahre zum innovations
Jahrzehnt entwickelt werden können eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung ist
unerlässlich dafür sorgen wir wir
brauchen keine schaufensteranträge der
Union die nicht dazu beitragen dass
unser Wissenschaftssystem Exzellenz
bleibt wie es ist vielen Dank
fordert hier für die Grünen unter
anderem dass die Forschungseinrichtungen
aus vom auch vom gaspreisdeckel gesetzt
profitieren sollten vielfach haben ja
auch Task Forces an Universitäten und
Forschungseinrichtungen jetzt schon
Maßnahmen zum Einsparen von Energie
umgesetzt
aus dem
Paralleluniversum in dem es überhaupt
gar kein Problem gibt zurück in die
leider Realität in der wir eben doch ein
Problem haben und diese Probleme wollen
wir lösen und es ist sehr von vielen
meiner Vorredner ein richtigerweise
schon gesagt worden wie herausragend die
Bedeutung der Wissenschaft der
wissenschaftsstandorts Deutschland ist
gerade in der Pandemie waren es nämlich
unsere Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die Tag und Nacht daran
gearbeitet haben geforscht haben dass
sie uns wieder ein Stück weit Normalität
auch zurückgeben können und jetzt
jetzt sind wir in der neuen Situation
die ist nicht weniger schwierig als die
alte leider kann uns halt jetzt die
Wissenschaft zumindest kurzfristig nur
bedingt weiterhelfen und trotzdem
forschen sie Tag für Tag an den
drängenden Problemen die wir alle haben
und an diesen oder an oder für die wir
auch einfach Antworten bringen brauchen
leider Fragen die von den anderen Krisen
im Moment überdeckt werden und umso
schlimmer ist es doch dass
offensichtlich die Regierung unsere
Wissenschaft mit unseren ForscherInnen
unseren Forschern zu stiefmüttlere
mütterlich bislang in dieser Krise